the fbi
has arrested brandon strzok founder of
the walk away campaign for his
involvement
in the capital riots and they're
alleging some pretty serious stuff like
he was telling people to do things
like go inside or take a cop's shield
and there's even a tweet
i remember seeing myself where brandon
said he told uh he tweeted that patriots
at the capitol hold the hold period the
period line
i saw him tweet that well i didn't know
exactly what it was about
but here we go fbi has made the arrest
we got a bunch of crazy stories so we'll
go through this but the craziest thing
about it
he was turned in by a relative according
to the fbi affidavit
the witness who handed over the evidence
claims to be
a relative of brandon strzok welcome my
friends to the great culture revolution
here in the united states where kids are
turning in their parents we got a couple
stories about that we'll
rehash just a little bit there's some
nuance in these stories we've also got a
story out of canada
they've apparently voted to label the
proud boys a terrorist
entity whether or not that actually
means anything has yet to be determined
i know a lot of people think it's legit
like it's done it's not it's not they're
calling
on the government to make it official so
we'll see how that plays out but
i got to tell you i wouldn't be
surprised if here in the us we see
something similar so you know there's
already
with democrat control of the house and
now essential control of the of the
senate
i wouldn't be surprised if they played
that same game now in in less
important news the articles of
impeachment have been delivered to the
senate
and there's going to be a trial and it's
kind of funny that we've actually have
this one slated for later like it's not
our lead story because
well it's just you know i got to be
honest it's kind of it's kind of silly
but then we have another big story too
we have a lot tonight actually
a hundred politico staffers have written
a letter outraged that ben
shapiro wrote an op-ed this is how crazy
things are getting so
i'll just i'll leave the intro at that
because we got a ton of stuff
and joining us tonight is brad palumbo
would you like to introduce yourself
brad
hey thanks for having me it's good to be
with you and what who are you what do
you do
so i'm a conservative journalist
washington examiner columnist and
podcast host just like yourself
right on so uh we'll have your we'll
have your opinions of course luke is
here no howdy we had a fun weekend
uh we shot a melon that jumped up six
feet in the air
that was pretty cool uh
well we shouldn't go into too much
details about exactly what we were doing
we had a lot of fun here we finally got
the shirts back
up personally that were banned that i
was wearing on this show that were
banned during the show
they're back up on the the best
political shirts.com
and yeah i mean it was a great weekend
we finally got the store back up
and uh we're doing great and uh yeah and
we also
finally got the i am a gorilla t-shirt
approved by youtube so now it's
pinned and official and uh uh i haven't
followed up yet i know teespring's
trying to been trying to get a hold of
me but i'm seeing a lot of people
if those aren't familiar a lot of people
are posting photos of the misprinted
iron gorilla shirts where his hands are
white and his face is darkened and uh
okay well teespring assured me that
won't happen again so i guess
we should be good if you want to buy the
iamagrilla t-shirt it should be normal
this time so hopefully we got ian
chilling he's wearing he's wearing
glasses what up everybody
coming at you who are you i'm ian
crossland
no intro you're gonna make me cuss yeah
and of course we got sour patch let's
press all the buttons i push all the
buttons in the corners i am i am proud
to say today
we have a sponsor and again look guys
i'm really really grateful whenever we
do get sponsors we don't have that many
okay these are trying times and i saw
someone already in the chat earlier said
that a bunch of the people they follow
and listen to have been purged yup keep
track because what they're doing is
they've always done this they go for the
smaller accounts first
because they make less noise and they
pick them off one at a time
if they ban a big channel it'll be too
noisy so they gotta be very careful
about how they do this
that being said i'm eternally grateful
because today's sponsor is virtual
shield
check out surfinginternetsafe.com and
you can get
50 off for life for their virtual
private network
service this is very very simple it's a
program that helps make you anonymous on
the internet
protects your private data from
third-party companies that want to sell
your stuff
it protects your information from
government from potentially from the
government i don't want to act like the
government is
are are weak when it comes to cyber
security but it really really does help
so again go to surfing internetsafe.com
stay home stay protected 50
off and they say that their vpn service
is compatible with all devices
and allows you to browse the web safely
securely and anonymously
using their global network of servers
and private ips they let you browse the
web completely anonymously
so the big name internet service
providers and other third parties will
not be able to monitor and sell your
internet activity
when using virtual shield your traffic
is routed through secure and encrypted
servers
this means that any restrictions
censorship blocks and unit are bypassed
enjoy browsing on a fast reliable secure
and always available network
and they say it is completely free for
the first 30 days so that's actually
really cool
i'll just give you one last little
tidbit because i'll explain to people
when you're surfing the web you're
basically you've got your front door
open
and like you can walk up it's kind of
convenient walk up the doors right open
right
that kind of doesn't make sense that you
should have some security in certain
circumstances i know maybe it's the
middle of the day you open your door you
get some fresh air it makes sense
but it makes sense to lock your windows
indoors at night virtual shield is a vpn
which provides you a basic level of
security
and i'm eternally grateful for their
sponsors for the show so make sure you
check out the link in the description
below surfing
internetsafe.com and you'll get 50 off
so much much
many many thanks and don't forget to go
to timcast irl.com become a member to
help support the show directly
so that in the event that you know we
eventually get purged um
we will still exist in some form and we
actually have this really great post-up
right now it's alex jones raiding luke's
rv
and waking him up that's not what you
think all right stop stop
dirty-minded people it is it is it's
actually really really calm you know a
lot of people who commented on it said
it's really cool because it's just like
alex being normal and saying hey luke
how you been and luke being like
so confused utterly confused it must
have been jarring
just waking up it was dark there's a
history there that hasn't been explained
i might do i might do my own sponsor
video on my own site explaining the
history there
but uh yeah it's it's but it's we also
we
also in this post have the lost episode
the one that youtube banned
so it's available there for members it's
also on bit shoot just you know just so
you know but we've made it convenient
for all of you so
many thanks everybody's become members
we can also see that the uh i am a
gorilla t-shirt is available now finally
integrated in youtube and you can get it
and hopefully
at this point everybody's getting the
corrected versions and
i guess we'll call the misprint one what
it is a misprint that we did not
sanction or endorse
and if you got it well then
congratulations but uh let's just jump
to the first story
man this story is this is nuts i was
sitting on my couch and i saw a tweet
brandon strzok
who's been on the show several times has
been arrested by the fbi
we have this local news outlet ketv 7
omaha says
omaha fbi agents arrest founder of walk
away campaign
for actions during u.s capital attack
they say brandon strzok 44 was arrested
monday by agents from the fbi omaha
field office
strzok faces charges of impeding a law
enforcement officer during civil
disorder
knowingly entering and remaining on
restricted grounds without lawful
authority
and or engaging in disorderly conduct
within proximity to a restricted
building
to impede official functions and
engaging in disorderly conduct with
intent to disturb a hearing before
congress
court documents show that officials were
tipped off about strzok
posting a video near the capitol
entrance shouting go go
the video was later removed and
officials said they could not find any
video or posts on his twitter page
relating to his actions the capital
however the fbi was sent multiple
screenshots
these screenshots were reportedly
revealed that strzok made the following
comments on twitter saying
quote patriots at the capitol hold the
line
quote i arrived at the capitol a few
hours ago as patriots were storming from
all sides
i was quite close to entering myself as
police began tear gassing us from the
door
i inhaled tear gas and got in my eyes
patriots began exiting shortly after
saying congress had been cleared
he goes on to say he was confused for
six to eight weeks everybody on the
right was saying 1776
and that if congress moves forward it
will mean a revolution so congress moves
forward
patriots storm the capital now everyone
is virtue signaling their embarrassment
that this happened
i think that quote right there is a
really good example of what happens when
you're in an echo chamber
as if anybody thought that going inside
a building and physically standing there
was going to change the government
overnight just
definitely not the case but the more
important points i'll make right here
they say according to documents one
video showed an officer from the u.s
capitol police holding a protective
shield
as individuals pushed past the officer
toward the entrance of the us capitol
the officer held his shield up in the
air the report states
according to documents strzok is heard
shouting take it away from him
and others in the crowd then yell take
the shield as several people in the
crowd
grabbed the officer's shield strzok
yelled take it take it
officials learn that strzok was a
self-described former liberal
and the founder of the walk away
campaign
now here's where it gets crazy i've got
here the fbi affidavit
they say the fbi received multiple tips
referencing the video of strzok at the
us capital
including a tip from witness one i
interviewed witness one on january 13th
witness one stated he she was a relative
of
strzok now everything else we've heard
for the most part accusations were made
videos were sent
and i'll also point out this is probably
why facebook banned walk away and all of
the people involved
see we didn't i don't think any of us
actually saw those videos unless you had
been following walk away i wasn't
so when i heard that they banned the
entirety of walk away i was like whoa
that's nuts
now if they're saying he was posting
these videos of himself storming the
capital it's not surprising at all
but i think the bigger the bigger issue
here is for one we got the news that's
it
founder of walk away arrested relative
turn them in
i mean play stupid games win stupid
prizes so i don't know why anyone went
near this mess at the capitol they were
never going to accomplish anything
they were never going to stop the
certification of the vote i mean
that ship sailed a long time ago for a
few hours they did
yeah they delayed the inevitable at a
big cost to them personally so
wait wait i disagree that that shaman
who believed he was an alien he was
definitely a threat to national security
and he he became very close to being the
speaker of the house
i mean how can you argue against that
well it was the insurrection
wait wait wait wait he was he was
standing in mike pence's place yes for
the
for the president of the senate that
that legally means he
was the president right that's that's
the idea isn't it by physically going in
there and standing there you you hold
the title that's the rules right well
that's what
is that what people thought was gonna
happen but okay look look look sorry for
interrupting
your point but i was saying like it is
disturbing to see people starting to
turn in family members it'd be one thing
right
if it was there was another story that
you and i were talking about before we
went live right where
there's a threat of like imminent
violence or terrorism but like just
snitching on your family members
there's got to be some really extreme
circumstances to justify anything close
to that
and just posts that you saw from them on
twitter i would never do that personally
well we also have to understand we're in
a political climate where it seems like
the fbi has been
absolutely activated previously before
when it when it came to other issues the
fbi is kind of sitting around but now
i mean they're putting up bulletin
boards they're putting up uh
wanted posters they're putting up tip
hotlines it looks like they finally you
know got off of their buttocks and
started being
extremely proactive and very efficient
at their job
when previously with other cases like
the epstein case they kind of didn't
really do much not just not just that
case here's the father there's no
no trust me there's a long piece of the
fbi not doing their job
correctly anybody who actually committed
crimes at the capitol they should be
doing that right
but where was that during the blm riots
this summer right they weren't tracking
down every person
but don't smash the window brad those
were peaceful
mostly peaceful and they stopped covid
and they bought covid
according to scientific studies that
were released and published by cnn news
are you telling me cnu
cnn news is lying and you're cutting me
down i'm telling you i'm gonna have to
speak louder
tim okay sorry go ahead oh no
i'm just telling you that when they when
they tell you it's mostly peaceful with
the burning background
with the building on fire it might not
actually be mostly peaceful
this is a serious a serious problem man
uh i've had emails from people saying
like tim
you talk about the same thing over and
over again just different times like
same
same stuff different day we don't wear
on the show and i'm like what do you
want me to do
like i'm telling you it's happening it's
happening i what i won't do is be like
oh i am i'm absolutely shocked by this
double standard
the fbi are arresting these
insurrectionists and
what we have antifa still riding now
like they've never stopped they're
crazy but look look i know you guys want
to rag on the fbi and all that
but i i got to point out the family
thing because you brought up that story
of the kid and his dad right
let me tell you how insane and
despicable things are getting we have a
story from the new york times
son tipped off fbi about his father who
was in who who is charged in capital
riot
he says i put my emotions behind me to
do what i thought was right
and you know what he thought was right
in his twitter on his twitter account
his his official link you know on
twitter you edit your profile you can
put a link
it's his link to a gofundme this morning
this morning
his gofundme was at like 90 something
thousand dollars
and i was just like dude it's one thing
to rat your family out
maybe you have to do it if there's a
real threat maybe you have to right it's
true
it's not it's not so simple it's another
thing to be like guys i turned my dad
and here's my gofundme
i'm looking for a hundred thousand
dollars and wait since then he's raised
another about 25 grand
so he increased the total goal to 200
thousand he's calling it his college
fund
listen this guy reported his dead weeks
ago
because his dad was saying he was going
to do something big and i'm like
look if your dad or your family member
was antifa
and they were talking about doing
something big especially when you have
stories of all these riots going on
and you turned them in i get it it's it
sucks
okay but then if you come out publicly
and you're like i'd like to do an
interview with with cnn in the new york
times and then publish a gofundme to
make hundreds of thousands of dollars
it's horrible wow dude well you yeah you
brought up a very important point
because
it could have been a scenario where
there was a present danger
and at that time you know we don't know
the interpersonal relationship we don't
know if there was abuse we don't know
any of this stuff but
at the same time one thing we have to
note here the mainstream media
especially cnn
they're taking this case and they're
running with it they're running
you know until the cows come home
essentially exploiting this and
and and loving it and and they're
running with it as
a headline story and this is where he
even wrote in his own
description he's like i'm getting so
much support after my cnn interview
i might not have a home to live in but
but it seems like he's
getting something you can buy a home now
that's the most dysfunctional
incentive structure though you're
setting up with these like resist bucks
i mean this is what they did with
claudia conway right that she was
willing to drag her dad on
her mom rather on twitter for working
for the president and so like the new
york times had a glowing profile of her
and they started constantly sharing her
and promoting her and turning her into a
tick-tock star
and it's like i don't think we should be
incentivizing with money
young people to do this kind of thing
and sell out their family unless you're
a commie and you want the culture
evolution
then you're then you're cheering and
jumping up and down and clapping for it
happy but wait i thought they didn't
believe in incentivizing people with
money
that's the funny thing i said you know
that's what i was saying earlier that
it's a lot of people claim to be
socialists or leftists but when it comes
down to it they're the
worst version of capitalists everything
they complain about capitalism like the
raw exploitation for money i'm like what
do you think it is you're doing
when you literally sell your dad to the
state for money
that's incredible look if i had to
report a family member i'd be
embarrassed i'd be i'd be saddened
but more importantly what if it was
possible he could have talked to his dad
what if when he heard his dad say crazy
stuff he was like yo dad sit down let me
talk to you
like we need to have a family
intervention about this because saying
i'm gonna do something big just you wait
what does that really mean it's crazy is
that is that when you're like well
something big time to call the feds
did he say it to the kid or did he write
it on twitter well well
later afterwards he told the kid he
would shoot him
so but that he reported he poured his
dead weeks ago
he so the dad told this kid that he was
at the capitol
and if he snitched on him he would do
you know what you know what traders
deserve and traders get
this sick guy sounds unstable i think
the kid's in the right here
well so his kid reported him weeks ago
all right and that's what
that's what i was saying a lot of people
are immediately jumping the gun saying
oh don't run on your family that's
messed up and i'm like i don't know if
your dad's saying like
no that's fine it's the fundraising part
that's right
is he so the kid's like homeless now is
did he lose his last parent no i don't
think so
well he he wrote in his i might be
kicked out of my house due to my
involvement
yeah i might be that's funny dude i got
sympathy for that guy that that kid
because that's a weird if your dad
threatens to shoot you and goes and does
some
illegal act that oh absolutely you have
to distance yourself from your family
when you're
younger than 18 is he imagine well it
could go either way we don't know his
future could be shattered we don't know
what happened personally between
these two individuals and their personal
relationship it could be that he was
making an
off-handed joke and wasn't that serious
about it it could be that he could be an
abusing father that beat his children
and literally threatened more harm on
them yeah you know so we don't know
exactly what happened there but again
it's the fundraising check this out
on his gofundme he keeps saying like i'm
raising
let me see let me see wow he goes i'm
raising the goal to a hundred thousand
from requests and it's staying at a
hundred thousand
thank you everyone for your messages
they all have been read and cherished
thank you
people have requested again that i moved
the goal post once more
i'm sorry about saying it saying it
would stay but you guys have been
persistent so i gotta ask for more money
i guess i gotta take more money there's
one more
i move the goal post once more people
have been requesting
it's just listen it's not me asking for
the money and increasing the goal it's
that people keep saying dude we want to
give you money
you don't need to increase the goal to
make money if your goal is five grand
people can still keep donating
increasing the goal has the purpose of
making people think you haven't reached
your goal yet so they're more likely to
donate
i doubt well no look there probably are
people saying like hey increase it right
and he's like i guess okay but just from
a raw perspective
you kind of have to respect the hustle
yeah oh yeah totally
he's a capitalist and and you know i'll
be completely honest the money he's
taking this is
this is a really funny question when it
comes to money people are like you're
getting paid by you know
soros or like the koch brothers or
whatever and i'm kind of like
who would you rather have the money the
koch brothers are me
like i kind of isn't it a good thing
that these organizations lose money
giving it away to other people
they they lose that power yeah we don't
you're kind of paid by the koch brothers
no the point i'm making is i don't know
what this dude's politics are
he's probably not particularly political
but he's now taken 125 grand
from you know establishment and
tribalist lefties so it's like i guess
better he has the money and spends it on
whatever he wants to than a bunch of
you know crazy people like it's better
than mitch mcconnell taking 150
000 from the nra probably because it's
like grassroots at least
wait what like we're talking about
people donating money and receiving
money like
these politicians that are getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
corporations
we don't sit here and talk and complain
about each of those but it's probably
way worse than a kid
going on gofundme and taking like this
what i'm saying is this kid's probably
gonna like buy a car
and then just like go drive around and
do nothing by crypto but the people who
have
money in the first place are gonna be
like promoting fringe political causes
and stuff so it's like
you know i guess he takes the money and
he just like you know goes to school
with it i guess
it he's influencing one person he's
paying them to influence him instead of
paying to influence others you know what
i mean
but it does incentivize more of this
right that's that's the main issue
that's why right if he gets it out then
a bunch of other kids out there whose
parents maybe
are not that crazy are going to see the
money
and maybe the next one i mean i'll give
this guy the full benefit of that maybe
his dad was crazy maybe
he had to do this right but there's
probably some kids out there who look at
that and are like
i want to get a slice of that and maybe
they will not be telling the truth when
they do it
yo the chick who turned in her mom
uh hold on wait is this the same one
oh there's many there's many of them
that's that's the thing
this didn't just once it happened a
couple times and
as you said you can only imagine if you
know your dad says eat your vegetables
your kid's going to look back at them
like i could call the fbi
butt talks right now the fool the nazis
and the
the communists the russian communists
soviets would would be like
turn them in do the right thing or maybe
or
through threat of force and now they're
doing it through bribery it's this new
world order
check it out the other the young woman
who turned her mother in
has raised 73 391 dollars
of her now 150 000 goal and of course
she's going pay for college
uh-huh well well to be fair biden's
gonna take a lot of that money with his
new tax plan
oh and and then college i mean well
they're going to get their student loans
off campus
anyway i'm going to tell you my hard
prediction i think these two people are
going to go to jail
or well kids yeah yeah yeah maybe maybe
not jail maybe it's a little harsh
i think because what people don't
realize i've heard this story a lot
when people get an internet windfall and
they think the money is free and they
don't pay taxes on it
and the irs comes in knocking and they
end up owing the irs a ton of money so
this dude who's getting all of this
money
for college could be argued that by
putting
that so i'm not a tax lawyer but you
know what i've been advised is
if you want to give someone a gift then
there can be no consideration
consideration being a contractual term a
legal term
so if i said like here you are luke one
gorilla
for free and you can do whatever you
want with it then that's a gift
but if i say this gorilla is 4x it's no
longer a gift
it depends though you could argue that
paying someone's medical bills or
college could constitute a gift
but we saw this i don't know if you guys
remember when occupy organized that big
debt payoff
where they were like buying people's
medical debt people were getting tax
bills because of it
because paying off someone's debt is
giving them money and then depending on
what the money was for if there was
consideration involved like
i'm gonna give you money but can only be
used for this then the person has to pay
taxes on it
a gift can have no strings attached well
right now with covet people are getting
tax bills for their stimulus checks and
their expended unemployment benefits
that's crazy that unemployment is a tax
you pay
unemployment tax to cover the
unemployment then they pay it out to you
but then they tax it
yeah so it's it's already a tax when you
spend it you pay sales tax to earn it
you pay income tax
to just keep your property you pay
property tax that i mean it's
multiplied a million times over at the
at the gun store where you went to
on the receipt when it said taxes it
said taxation is theft
oh did it say you got to check your
receipt you'd love to see it yeah
so i mean there's local businesses that
are hit either way i mean you brought up
an important point i mean they tax
almost
there's so many aspects of life are
taxed you receive money you
you get taxed you spend money you get
taxed and then you got to pay taxes on
top of those taxes
on top of other taxes that's just this
is but hold on that's all
this is why what a lot of these lefties
understand is that lowering the tax rate
can actually increase tax revenue
oh yeah because if the dollar if i have
one dollar and we we spread it around
this table
by the time the dollar is done being
traded the government has all of it
all of it but if you raise the taxes to
a point where i can't even afford to
spend it then i just hold the dollar
well and also none of it high taxes
discourage economic activity right if
the top rate is 90
like aoc's dream right people aren't
going to work to earn those extra
dollars
once they hit that bracket then there's
less overall revenue from that too
i disagree um you're you're right but
they just do clever
it's a it's a rich people's game once
they get to that point they're just like
they just buy other things that don't
get taxed they just open up a charity
and that's one of the biggest scams out
there just like bill gates who said he's
going to give all of his money
away to charity and then tripled his
wealth somehow in those panama
trippers didn't get enough attention did
you guys pay attention to those when
they dropped the package yeah
the person who leaked it die or
something oh my god i don't know
but all these really wealthy people have
bank accounts and
celebrities or they're about i know one
of putin's best friends has
tons of money there he's like the
musician guy i mean that's
we that's like the elephant in the room
it with this economy right so it's rich
people
have the means and the ability and the
legal power and they get away with
you're like
are you like a tax lawyer no no not a
lawyer but no but i do i report on
economics and write about economics and
that's been one of the most interesting
things about covid and the big response
like the federal reserve printed
trillions of dollars essentially a lot
of it went to big corporations
a lot of the paycheck protection program
which was supposed to help small
businesses
went to big corporations this is this
happens all the time with government
this is why the swamp is actually one of
the truest things trump ever said
right in washington even the progressive
legislatures
legislators get called by all the big
companies every day and get tons of
money from them
and make sure that the big bill doesn't
hurt their bottom line it's all
like that there's a study where they say
something like
public opinion has zero impact on public
policy
and the opinions of major corporations
and the wealthy
impacts almost exclusively makes sense
why why is a politician going to be
worried about well i think the internet
has changed things though
because it used to be that you needed
the money to get to run the ads
now it's it's the twitter game it's you
know aoc goes on twitter and she starts
ranting about the republicans and like
how they're evil
and stuff like that and then she gets
more and more followers and they just
people love to hate they love to be
angry
you know they want to feel their anger
is justified
well that's the impulse that gathers
your attention
the most so there have been many
clinical studies and if you could make
someone
fearful and scared those are the
incentives to make people click
more than anything else out there in the
internet and a lot of these news
companies a lot of these big tech
companies know this
and they they need to keep people on
their platforms they need to keep people
uh you know engaged as much as they can
so they so they hit this
fear uh what is it uh what is it flight
fight or flight fight or flight
instincts all the time and our
emotional systems are hyperbolically
just going insane after being induced
into so much of this kind of casino
gamified
informational warfare that's blasted in
your face well let's let's jump into the
next story then cause this is perfect we
have this from
globalnews.ca mps unanimously
agree to urge feds to designate proud
boys a
terrorist entity so i see a lot of
tweets from people saying like canada
just declared the proud boys were
terrorists well
politically the mps kind of did but
there's been no official declaration
from their federal government
they say members of canada's parliament
have agreed to call on the federal
liberal government to formally designate
the proud boys a terrorist entity
the motion introduced by ndp leader
jagmeet singh
passed with unanimous consent in the
house of comments on monday
the motion calls upon the government to
use all available tools to address the
proliferation
of white supremacists and hate groups
starting with the immediate designating
the proud boys as a terrorist entity
the ndp has for weeks been calling on
trudeau and the liberals to ban
the proud boys and designate the group a
terrorist organization
the move comes after thousands of
supporters of president trump or you
know storm the capital yeah yeah we get
it
members of the proud boys were
reportedly present during the writer
isn't joe biggs a proud boy
um i think so yeah i don't know how much
he called but he got arrested he got
arrested so so they were there
and enrique tario was supposed to be
there but he got arrested and they
kicked him out of dc
the federal government said it is
considering designating the group as a
terrorist entity
as minister blair has said we strongly
denounce ideologically motivated
extremists including groups like the
proud boys
white supremacists anti-semitics
islamophobic and misogynist groups
mary liz power a spokesperson for public
safety minister bill blair told the
global news earlier this month
intolerance and hate have no place in
our society
think about what this means how often do
we see the proud boys go around and
actually
smash things up and destroy things and
cause violence really it happens
sometimes
rarely though how often do we see it
from antifa designated happiness
tonight yes it just happened last night
yeah tacoma washington yep smashing up
windows and just when
joe biden got uh inaugurated they
smashed up the democrat headquarters
windows and everything and destroyed it
and where's the fbi
i mean i i know in canada this is canada
we're talking about with proud boys
but let's just talk about antifungal
because antifa operates in canada
i mean they're in the pacific northwest
so they go up and down all the time do
the pride
proud boys even operate in canada i
don't even know if they had
probably been right there personally to
be honest with you it's it's remarkable
they're trying to claim like what did
they do in canada like
i think the goal is they're desperately
trying to redefine what white supremacy
means and i think they've they've
succeeded
there's no point in calling out the
double standard okay it's like all the
time the conservative's like there's a
double standard it's obvious yeah dude
no duh
the left knows this they don't care and
you saying something does literally
nothing because they're not going to
stop
now they're at the point where they've
redefined white supremacy white
supremacy is totally redefined in media
and now because they've redefined it
they can now claim the proud boys are
white supremacists even though their
chair is
literally not quite from what i
understand about the proud boys there's
a lot of things not to like about the
group but
racism and white supremacy is not one of
them right but the real concern too is
that when they're designating things
terrorist groups that's a precursor to
infringing civil liberties
that's a justification for surveillance
for limiting speech
and that is something you've got to
watch against because that's how
authoritarianism creeps in
they've actually started to do something
similar in the u.s here after the
capital attack
tulsi gabbard has come out and warned
against this don't let them use the
capital attack
as an excuse to expand the national
security state and crack down on civil
liberties
to be fair i think rashida taleb did as
well she did and i'm a huge critic of
her but i was like okay rashida go off
queen
yes i don't i agree i won't say that
very often but
they need to magnify the threat to of
course get what they want and that's
more power more authority for them and
you know if the proud boys did commit to
terrorism if there was a terrorist
attack done by the proud boys
yeah label them a terrorist organization
but can you even
tell me an act or or a single day where
the proud boys did anything in canada
that justifies well not so much canada
but there was canada that one time where
that guy
was walking out the street and he got
shot oh wait that was antifa who shot
and killed
the trump supporter sorry yes um there
was the time
the proud boy um he was going to fight
back against someone got whacked with a
with a with a retractable baton
and i guess he became those proud boys
all in black with their faces no that
was anti though oh that was antifa
but not no to to be realistic there was
in new york when antifa showed up to the
gavin mcguinness speech
and then the proud boys ran at antifa
beat the crap out of him and then
started laughing about it and streaming
it
and they went to prison for it so even
when they actually do
you know it the proud boys argue they
didn't start the fight because antifa
was surrounding and harassing
and antifa did rob a guy who was leaving
the event
still if you're not like le don't don't
swing you know defend and if they if
they start a fight well then
i understand defending yourself and
ending that fight but you don't want to
be the person starting the fight now
these guys went to jail
it's also because they cooperated with
cops the cops were like what happened
here's exactly what happened they said
okay gang violence going to prison
antifa
refuse to cooperate they're gone they're
safe now i'll tell you how things get
creepy
we're talking about canada right oh this
is gonna have a direct and immediate
impact on all of the proud boys united
states you know why
you guys know about the five eyes spy
club right mm-hmm
yeah luke i know you do ian yeah i know
i've heard of it i don't know no
so we got what we got canada australia
australia new zealand the us and what is
it south africa uh or the uk the uk
united kingdom yes the five i spy club
it's very clever it's really simple you
see
spying on american citizens actually
against the constitution's illegal right
you can't theory in theory no no but but
in a lot of ways it's it's there's still
some barriers
what happens if canada spies on an
american citizen and then the u.s says
hey canada you know anything about
enrique tario
you called him a terrorist are you
spying on them we are can we can we look
at that yes you can i see how this works
yikes yeah and it's been that way for a
long time it was actually
it was edward snowden i think who
revealed a lot of this stuff
this this manipulative the circuitous
game they play where
well you can't spy on people in the u.s
but australia can
there's probably still some restrictions
on whether or not the us is allowed to
look at certain things and can be sued
over
but look at what happened with michael
flynn and unmasking well
theory was the right and look at there's
probably so much more that we don't know
about because people like snowden don't
get the pardon
right and so there's so many
whistleblowers that probably haven't
come forward
uh because of that so the surveillance
state and the spying is always crazy but
it always is crazy because it's only
like the tip of the iceberg
you know there's so much more there that
we don't know about and i wonder
sometimes just how bad and how pervasive
it actually is dude hold on hold on hold
on
what what you smoke bombs smoke bombs
yes
so we we went to an airsoft uh store and
we got some airsoft stuff and and some
of it is just like the colored smoke so
for like signaling and
you know i don't think it's really good
for a smoke screen is it no no i just
feel like signaling your side or
whatever
for like 10 seconds we didn't we didn't
post anything
our ads were like dog food and stuff
because you know luke's got a dog and
then we were downstairs and the box on
the shelf no one mentioned it no one
talked about it nothing was going on we
didn't go to any stores
it's been weeks and then luke was like
should we try one out
sure picks it up throws it and we sit
there and we're like meh whatever we go
inside
was it 20 minutes later yep i checked my
phone and it's an advertisement for
smoke bombs yeah we didn't but this is
like this is like the fifth time
something like this has happened
uh so it's uh utterly you know if
facebook has that
type of technology imagine what the cia
has or
other intelligence agencies you know the
cia like the former head of john brennan
that compared
libertarians uh as well and
nativist as a threat to national
security as a threat
to national democracy um you know there
was this uh
twitter user spike cohan and he said
this
this stuck with me very much he said
quote a libert um
a silver lining to the biden
administration labeling libertarians
terrorists
is that soon the cia will probably start
giving us money and weapons now
and i'm like yeah this is my spike
bowhunt spike cohen not my idea but i'm
like that that's
probably makes a lot of sense repeats
that's exactly what's going to happen
here but we're seeing this kind of
you know this term of white supremacy
being vagued all the way to
nativists libertarians well everything i
don't like is racism and then i don't
have to engage in actual political
argumentation
exactly but the losers there are the
actual victims of racism because when
everything is racism
nothing is yeah so it what it actually
just undermines and dilutes the word
because real racism that we literally
would all agree is horrible
and it obviously does still exist but
when they've just started becoming
calling everything they don't like
racism you know why they're doing it
to win the argument because they're
racist no no but but seriously
so you look at the efforts in california
to repeal their civil rights act and
their constitution yes
they're racist they want special laws
for people based on race
we who don't like racism oppose that
well this is like joe biden he said that
he will be conditioning his covet
stimulus aid
to specifically favor african-americans
and different minority groups
that's illegal that is it's definitely
illegal but also it's like
the opposite of american values right we
want or at least we used to want
equality under the law and now they're
like actually we
want inequality under the law but woke
this this spying thing reminds me of uh
captain america winter soldier
where the bad guys hydra develop an
algorithm
where they can target base you know
people who are basically deviant
and then their plan is to just kill them
all with these airships that's what the
movie's about
so i have to wonder facebook it has been
reported
knows when you will poop what yeah yeah
no yes oh yes 100 how so
first considering the power of their ai
i think
the average person could just be like
yeah i'd imagine their their their
algorithms and artificial intelligence
are strong enough to determine and make
these predictions but it's actually
really simple
you have a pattern of behavior they know
where you work right
you're in your house your phone location
service is on every morning around 8 am
you leave and go to starbucks where you
work
they know then you leave starbucks
around noon and go to mcdonald's
they know when you ate they have general
understanding of the average person's
you know
you know waste cycle after eating but
they also know when you enter
a room and stop moving so they can
actually now
predict when you will be going to the
bathroom they know actually where you
will eat before you do
so there's they're simple things that
that you know these algorithms can find
if somebody let's let's say on your
location services you went to
uh salad works or whatever i'm sure this
place probably right and they're like
okay someone who ate leafy greens is
more likely to do this tomorrow
yeah people don't realize these these
these simple things that are seemingly
meaningless
have a huge impact let's say they see
that you've gone to
um an ice cream shop or whatever they're
gonna be like okay tomorrow he's not
gonna be feeling well because he's
eating a bunch of sweets and candy
they can predict your behavior think
about how simple it is look
if someone told me i went and got a
whole bunch of taco bell last night i'm
like oh you're gonna be taking a dump
for a long time
no offense taco bell your food's good
but that's when the premium
advertisements come in after the taco
bell now people are gonna get taco bell
ads yes
no no but like if someone told you they
went ate a bunch of garbage fast food
you would immediately assume like your
stomach's gonna be screaming at you
think about what an ai can can discern
based on all of these other things
i'd imagine the cia knows what you will
do before you do it
like pre-crime especially with all the
selfies everyone keeps taking and photos
of themselves i mean some people take
like hundreds photos hundreds of photos
of themselves and i'm like
what do you think you're doing with that
you think there's i mean oh it's all
being fed into these machines like this
was another big story that
these selfies are automatically being
scraped by
mit and other institutions to create
artificial intelligence
how do you you know you know they do the
face morphing app it's because they have
everyone's faces and then they've
like created an algorithm that tracks so
why is it that no one cares when i talk
to other people my age right like other
people in their 20s and you tell them
you know that alexa the fbi can hear you
right now they're like lol
okay they've grown up like that and i
guess people really don't care how do we
make them care
i don't know uh i don't think they ever
will it's it depends on how much the
government uses that power to overreach
but ultimately look if look if you're a
criminal
and you're at home and you say something
about what you did
and it's used as evidence then you're a
dumb criminal like you have right
there was there was actually a story
where there was a murder i guess and
someone had one of those fancy little
amazon devices
and it recorded like everything that
happened and then they were like how
oh you know it just uh
i don't know it must have been an
accident no it's recording everything
you say
in order to actually know you're talking
to it it has to have its microphone
turned on
all the time now they say they're not
really tracking or anything and maybe
that's true but i just kind of don't
think it is i think you have to be naive
to think so
well this is the crazy thing this has
been happening for a very long time even
before edward snowden
i remember walking up to the head of the
nsa and the cia general hayden
and i asked him hey your nsa agents were
caught
uh spanking it to people's private
photos
that through their text messages before
snowden he was like no does it no that
never happened i'm like
yes it did there was even mainline
mainstream news articles about this and
he lied right through his teeth
john brennan also another individual
former head of the cia
lying through his teeth and now he's
bragging about
biden's intelligence agencies being
laser focused
on libertarians and i mean it's
absolutely insane something crazy have
you ever seen the photos of mark
zuckerberg at work
yep and now you see his computer yep
he's he's got his tape he's got tape
over here
not just that but also the the
microphone right also
but wait there's more so there's a phone
uh it's called the oneplus
7 or something like that and it has a
manual mechanical camera
so the front-facing camera has to
actually go
like come out the top most phones the
front-facing camera is just right there
always staring you in the face
you'll notice people like zuckerberg
will put tape over it
so my friend who has the oneplus with
the mechanical camera noticed that
randomly on different websites the
camera would just open
like uh what like but think about it
think about it
that would freak you out right right why
doesn't it freak you out that you've got
a camera on the front of your phone
all the time and you never know when
it's filming a kid born into
okay if there's like a flood we would
all be like oh there's a flood we got to
do something
but then if kids are born during the
time while the floods already happening
it's not just normal yeah
the new york post also had an article uh
not so long ago and their title was
covering up the camera could damage your
laptop apple wow and then below it
all the comments are like nice try
but this is but but we got to understand
the larger implications here because we
have a president
joe biden who bragged he openly bragged
in 2001
about how he wrote the patriot act in
1994
and how it was right-wingers and
libertarians who fought against it i
started
my video off started with him saying
look what i did i did this i created the
patriot act now we're passing it through
after 9 11.
now they're talking about working a new
patriot act 2.0 that many prominent
democrats are bringing forward that will
give them even more
surveillance power than they already
have already nsa agents were caught
spanking it to your private text
messages and your private photos
now they want even more i mean what's
next literally taking your girlfriend
and you know doing oh god yeah what's
next what is next
the thing is though when they get these
powers they say it's for one thing and
they do it for another thing so with the
patriarch they said it was for terrorism
you look back at the data i don't know
exactly it's like 97 drug cases yeah so
they get these powers
in the name of terrorism or whatever
they label it and that probably in
at least 911 sure was a real thing but
then they know that they're going to use
these powers for all sorts of things
to just screw over the little guy as
they literally finance the terrorists
right
literally so so it's like how can i
trust the guys that are that are
shipping in toyota trucks
all the latest ammunitions all the
latest night vision gear all the latest
armory equipment possibly
to isis al qaeda and al-nusra telling me
that they're fighting terrorism and
i need to give up my freedoms because of
al-qaeda fighting terrorists
but you have to admit it was really
funny to see isis driving around in that
truck with the detroit plumbers like
phone number on it you ever see that so
there's like a video of like isis guys
in a truck and the truck says like you
know jim bob's plumbing detroit with a
phone number and people are like
what how did that happen yeah and
they're like oh it's because you know
the u.s is sending it over there
we were also talking about getting a 50
cal and i was
actually looking at the history of the
beretta 50 cow and it became prominent
because the cia bought it and we're
literally giving it to al qaeda to fight
the russians
oh my gosh no no no no no the the 50 cow
the philly the 50 cows is in the desert
eagle 50 caliber uh no no we're talking
about the
the like anti-material ants yeah that
one specifically
that we're thinking about i'm uh
purchasing reading a little bit about
spy satellites there's been some great
leap
forward in the great leap forward was
that a that was a communist mouth thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's a great
thing so there's been some great leaps
forward in spy satellite tech um they
can they have this thing called the
capella 2 which can use radio
beams to pulse through your building and
measure energy inside the building they
say that you can't actually
record people inside their building yet
but uh they may have been measuring your
smoke
bombs outside and been like oh so they
heard you on the amazon machine
your phone was triangulating that you
were at the airsoft store
and then radio telescopes are seeing the
smoke clouds i don't think they'll do
all that to sell an ad
i don't think they would either but i
don't think they wouldn't
they have lasers that they can point at
a window and then the words you say
vibrate on the glass
and they can listen yeah i've heard that
they can listen through your house from
space
yeah well i don't know about from space
maybe i wouldn't be surprised like
you have to imagine the stuff we know
about is nothing compared to what they
were right
this is the stuff they finally revealed
on in december of 2020.
but also think about like we're talking
about what facebook can do wow i wonder
what the the feds and the cia can do
it's like dude they don't have to do
much you're walking around with a
microphone and a camera yeah
and a tracking device all day they don't
know where tonight with facebook with
amazon and with like
you know boston dynamics and other
capella these companies
you know companies to get all the texts
to work together i'll tell you
no one's going to care until people like
as long as people
are fat they're happy you know i mean
you give people food
and you're not gonna get a revolution
it's i just don't see it
you know what i mean like you you might
get for whatever reason these people
storming the capital thinking there's a
revolution going on but
like i think what what we've seen in
many instances
for the most part people have to be in
in real dire straits where they feel
desperate
and nothing can solve this problem but
as long as people are being fed
they'll sit around and just eat you know
what i mean yeah they're not really
scared
well they feel like they have nothing
else to hide but they better hope they
never piss off anybody powerful
i mean that's that's how this goes it's
it's never the well off and well
connected who have to worry about the
government
infringing on their rights or screwing
them over no it's going to be the little
guy and
it might be too late at that point i
mean actually i i disagree a little bit
uh it's it's if you're in the club
you're in the club but there are
probably some people who up will gain
upward mobility and that's when you're
in trouble
do they need to remove you if you get it
if you go up the wrong way
yeah like if you're if you're a joe the
plumber why would they care they're
gonna be like i don't know if they need
a patsy i guess but then it's like a
lottery ticket's chance they frame you
or whatever i just don't see that
what i do see is they're gonna be
they're gonna be keeping a hard
eye on anybody who might gain too much
power and threaten
their club and their you know the upper
elites and all this stuff i mean that's
what bill benny
look at trump yeah well bill benny bill
benny said this a long time ago he was
he was
at uh the intelligence agencies saying
why are we collecting data on everyone
everything why are we catching this vast
net
and losing ourselves in it when we could
do strategic
spying on actual jihadis on actual
threats that pose a danger
to the american people but we're not
doing that we're not effective at
stopping any terrorism
at all because we're collecting as much
as we can what are we going to be doing
with all of that
i'll tell you exactly what happened so
there's bill benny he's an nsa nsa
whistleblower right
uh yes and he's and he's he's he's
talking to some guys like isn't it weird
you know that we're not actually
stopping any terror and the guy laughs
and goes bill it's because we do it
and then bill goes wait what and the fbi
guy goes
wait what and throw him out of the
building like oh he wasn't supposed to
know that was he
well he retired and then of course he
faced you know the prosecution
for whistleblowing and revealing that
the government was spying on every
little thing
this was way before snowden these
revelations he was like i was telling
you they could do this but he didn't
have the hard documents
he's been saying that's fine every phone
call they know exactly what you're doing
all the time
he went through the official chain of
command and whistleblowed officially and
they still went after him
and they still heard him you know and it
took edward snowden literally
taking the documents releasing them to
glenn greenwald and getting them out
there to the world
and there's still a lot of questions
about right where's the rest of the
documents as well
think about this if this is what the us
government is doing what is china doing
yeah what are they doing with tick tock
yeah what are they doing with all the
data they have on americans they're
watching you poop
right they're they're probably doing
more than that they're probably watching
you to
create blackmail files on everybody
that's going to end up working for the
government
and right so they can shake you down and
right now there's like an nsa guy an fbi
and a cia guy and they're all watching
this podcast with like popcorn
like yeah it's totally right about china
like that's a good point but they're not
watching the show on youtube they're
watching through our phone cameras
like luke made a really good point are
you watching uh tim gaster yeah but
i'm assigned to ian so it's funny
there's a meme
about my fbi agent have you ever seen
that oh yeah yeah
it's like people like it's a joke it's
like haha and we know what's happening
and we don't care
eventually you know you know i think the
main issue is whether or not
they abuse the power like you know
cranking it to someone's girlfriend or
something and getting caught doing it
which they did right right right it's
it's it's are they actually going to
infringe on your life
i feel i care about it but i feel
overwhelmed as if we're in an
avalanche that's going down the mountain
and we're in the snow like
ah like i care that there's an avalanche
but
i'm not concerned with stopping the
avalanche right now but concerning
surviving it's all about positive mental
attitude okay so we're in the avalanche
right i just will the avalanche to stop
no no no no no no it's
all these people are screaming i'm just
sitting back i see how much goes down
and i'm chilling
it's kind of fun you know what i mean
like when you when you're skydiving and
like you realize your parachutes down
you're like well at least i get to enjoy
myself
so we know the avalanche is going to go
off the cliff and we're all doomed ride
the avalanche that could be another
shirt just surfing
you know what i mean you can't stop
where the amateur's going but you can
throw down your board and just
cruise while you can and there's this
thought that maybe we can stop the
avalanche
or or redirect the avalanche no because
if anyone becomes a threat to derailing
the narrative
derailing the agenda that's set for you
the nsa the fbi with their predictive
programming algorithms with their
pre-crime technology could
figure that out they could say oh
they're he's growing in popularity he's
getting a lot of followers he's reaching
a big mass of people
we need to intervene because he's
heading towards the trajectory towards
actually making some
substantial changes in our government
yes stop immediately you're overthinking
it
they don't need to do that because they
have their shills
and their useful idiots already which
brings me to the next story
yahoo news 100 plus politico staffers
send letter to ceo railing against
publishing ben
shapiro and this is an example so what
we're just talking about
is that if you if you're starting to
become too influential too powerful
they'll come after you try and take you
down if what you're saying goes against
the established narrative they will try
and stop you
ben shapiro is fairly mainstream
conservative so he's not
right threatening but there are many
people and they've been banned parlor
for instance
parlor's a threat to the narrative
banned now ben shapiro is still
not perfectly aligned so he's just
outside where they want the narrative to
be
here's what happens yahoo says
more than 100 politico staffers signed
onto a letter to publisher robert
albritton expressing disgust with
allowing right-wing firebrand ben
shapiro
to guest author one day's edition of the
playbook
and with the outlet subsequent handling
of the fallout earlier this month the
beltway news outlet
handed over the keys to its signature
news product to shapiro
a talk radio host and pundit who has
long been one of the most controversial
voices in right-wing media
that's actually 100 not true in
right-wing media
ben shapiro is not controversial at all
he's actually fairly
i mean yeah well i was going to say with
all due respect tepid
like you're not turning on ben shapiro
and hearing some ranting lunatic calling
for insurrection you're hearing a guy
giving his opinion and it's like clear
yeah he's a lawyer and it's very much
like oh that was a good point ben and
it's very normal
but the worst thing about this is that
it's journalists doing it to me
i can say this as a journalist they're
not journalists okay they're people who
call themselves journalists
and if you're a journalist and you don't
believe in open debate and free speech
and you think other people's ideas make
you unsafe
right you are not a journalist learn to
code do something else because you do
not belong in this look i'm gonna get
banned for that yeah
but it's seriously it's sick i mean
these people have come to see
ostensibly neutral outlets like politico
is not supposed to be a left-wing thing
it's not supposed to be jacobin right
as their zones were even just a
momentary one-day
intervention of a conservative voice
violates their safe space makes them
feel betrayed by the institution they
work for
that is diagnostic of a sick mentality
well here's what they say according to
multiple politico insiders familiar with
the situation
the letter to albritton all britain
criticized the decision to publish
shapiro claiming it had demoralized a
substantial portion of the newsroom
but also railed against the response to
criticism offered by editor-in-chief
matt kaminsky
it's an internal matter and will be
handled as such a political spokesperson
told the daily beast
during a combative meeting on january
14th the day of shapiro's publication
the top editor defended the editorial
decision to irate staffers by claiming
mischief making has always been a part
of politico's secret sauce
we were an upstart some of that
sensibility is always going to be a part
of this publication
the staff letter sent last week to all
britain maintained that kaminsky had not
appropriately
apologized for his responses
additionally referencing an email he
said to staff on january 15th
which is obtained and reviewed by the
daily daily beast
the top editor expressed regret for his
initial response about making mischief
but reiterated that publishing shapiro
was part of his hopes to experiment
and mix things up and that's why they
don't like it
because i'm sure there are a lot of new
conservatives who came to politico and
liked what they were seeing and
there are probably some moderates who
heard an opinion that heard before but
let me tell you why this is all bs it's
very very simple
remember when there was a collective
screen
that we all could physically hear when
tom cotton wrote an op-ed saying send in
the troops
it was like one day i just heard and i
was like what's happening up in my mind
i could hear it everywhere i was aw
all of these left is screaming in news
media by the way
about how awful it was that they dared
publish this in the new york times
send in the troops tom cotton said to
end the riots in portland
and uh then they sent in 25 000 troops
to washington dc
to prevent an insurrection oh but that's
different
that's okay now they're all happy now
they're all like
well it's good that we have our security
here they're keeping us safe apparently
nancy pelosi requested crew-manned
machine guns
in a civilian yes this is uh um was it
ken cuccinelli
i think he said this yeah it's it's it's
it's a remarkable
in a civilian town in a city i know
there's federal jurisdiction
reported i should say cancun johnny said
she requested this of them
could you imagine what would happen if a
bunch of unarmed trump supporters well
some of them were armed but a large
group of angry trump supporters were
like waving trump flags and like shaking
a fence
and then nancy pelosi was like use the
crewman machine guns
there's civilian buildings nearby you
can't do that are you nuts
so apparently they were like no no we
don't do that here
like that's how things go where is the
outcry from the left now
so they're complaining about ben shapiro
no it's not fair you're publishing him
but we know their their complaints are
bs
it's there's no conservative they would
accept i mean right unless a
conservative that's just going to
confirm all their beliefs and go totally
never trump and become
jennifer rubin you know max boot but
here's the thing that bothers me too
it's not even that they were objecting
to the content of what he wrote
they were objecting to just him as a
person being allowed to speak in that
platform because of like
tweets from 2007 or something that upset
them
it would be actually at least something
we could fight against and debate if
they were saying that column was
bad and shouldn't have been published no
one cares about none of these people
freaking out about it could tell you
what he wrote
most of them didn't even read it i would
bet i don't even know a thousand dollars
it was about impeachment
it was about saying well here's why
senate republicans aren't going to
support impeachment
i talk to them they tell me this it was
not even very opinionated he said
democrats
but if my wife was a doctor right the
funny thing is he does have a style that
can be uh
like you said kind of combative but he's
very mainstream he's
not he's not the razor fire brand that
you'd think these people couldn't handle
if they can't handle him
there's no one they can handle but the
problem is that they framed their
opposition to him as a matter of safety
and that will never stop bothering me
ben shapiro's ideas make other people
unsafe
well then there's something wrong with
you you're not an adult you need to
return to fifth grade
and develop the emotional stability of a
grown human being but you know what man
i read the story a long time ago
about this family that was on a beach
and then it was like it was a dad
his wife and they're like two kids and
then all of a sudden they saw a large
black wolf
walking down the beach and they panicked
and they swam
out to this rock that was like you know
20 30 feet
out and they huddled together on it
shaking
dripping wet for warmth as the wolf
paced back and forth
and it was like this harrowing
experience the men had recounted
and i was thinking about that and i'm
like i wonder what would have happened
200 years ago
would he have pulled out his like
flintlock pistol and his sword and said
protect the kids
bang and then like drew his sword to
protect them from the wild beast
or would they have hid and shivered and
imagined back in the day when we were
faced with these very serious challenges
and men literally walked around
armed all the time something like that
probably wouldn't have happened
it was a couple hundred years ago well
let's say even a hundred years ago
that probably would have had a gun on
his belt you know when he was and he
probably would have just shot the thing
or something like that
now today's day and age you still have
circumstances where a dude who lives out
in the middle of nowhere his family is
gonna be
armed but what the point i'm bringing up
is like i read that story and i thought
to myself like
would that would like are we gradually
just getting weaker and more scared of
everything i think the answer is yes
and this story is a perfect example ben
shapiro's opinions now make you unsafe
you have these colleges where they say
things like that you know
their speech is violence like they
literally now think the
but think about it you have these kids
who grow up where they get participation
trophies
where no one's allowed to pick on them
or insult them in any way and then they
actually
they probably feel real physical pain
they can't deal with when someone calls
them like a stupid doo-doo head they're
like
it hurts i've never experienced this
pain before it feeds into itself
right because if you start not being
exposed to different ideas or different
opinions
you don't ever develop the thick skin
and then it just becomes more and more
out of control to the point where they
because the thing is when they can frame
other people's speech as violence
or endangering their safety that is the
the necessary precursor they have to get
to logically argue they should be
allowed to shut down that speech
preemptively
because if it's just really offensive
most people won't agree they should be
able to shut it down well to bypass the
first amendment
right exactly even do that here they
said that this demoralized the newsroom
and most of their complaint was this the
with this guy who said that
part of what politico did was cause
mischief so they're not even saying that
it was making them feel like that
danger how pathetic was it lies how
pathetic was it even claim having been
shapiro write an op-ed was mischief
it's not it's really not he's a
mainstream high-profile prominent
conservative one of the biggest podcasts
in the world
it was boilerplate too the actual
article the article was not
controversial he's written some
controversial books
right it wasn't like he was writing
about trans issues it wasn't like he was
writing about abortion
he was explaining senate republicans
rationale on impeachment
it's like you said they were objecting
to him yes he could have walked and said
hey i'm ben shapiro and they would went
like
they let him in the building and they
would all scream and like one guy jumps
out the window
then he's like okay but i will say it
only helps him
right it's like it is an example of like
they only confirm everything he says
about the liberal media when they do
stuff like this and they don't seem to
realize that they're just
making they're proving his point and
they're only propping him up that's
another thing we have to understand here
like this is
this is backfiring and lucky luckily it
is because sometimes it doesn't and they
get their way
but we can't give uh give our way to
these people that are
i think clinically insane i mean if
you're at a point in life where hearing
words
makes you feel pain what's what's wrong
with you and
again i keep reminding people one of the
most important powers you have as a
human being
is the power of your reaction i got i i
gotta i gotta add to this you know just
to say i'm i'm i'm not a long-time gun
person
you know i i always tell the story in
january of last year i was like i don't
want any guns at my house now we got a
bunch luke's talking about buying a 50
count all
like yeah okay so we like guns and uh i
remember seeing that story from
the journalist who claimed he got ptsd
from firing an ar-15
do you have you ever sorry yeah who did
you write was i think it was abc
i'm not sure he fired an ar and i i wha
what
that was probably like six yeah and he
claimed that he got ptsd from shooting
it he could feel the shock wave
and it hurt his arm and all that and i'm
like here's what's funny
because it's something i didn't
understand until actually experienced it
game load for a shotgun when you're
hunting turkeys
has more recoil is a bigger explosion
than an ar-15
so when like when we went to the range
and we had bird shot i'm like man you
can feel that bird shot
and then when you're finding the ar it's
like actually not that
much at all relative so if this guy is
getting ptsd from an ar-15 complaining
it's like it's a weapon of war and
he could he was traumatized from it i'm
like well heaven forbid you have to hunt
a turkey
it was like wow it was the daily news
the title was what is it like to fire an
ar-15
it's horrifying menacing and very very
loud
in 2016. fittingly
[Music]
it's 2016 and the first
headline here it says it felt to me like
a bazooka and
sounded like a cannon he said he said
the explosions loud like a bomb
gave me a temporary form of ptsd for at
least an hour after firing the gun just
a few times i was anxious and
irritable that's kind of offensive to
ptsd victims yes
very much so my favorite image that
people have posted on this is a meme
is a little girl with a pink shotgun
shooting
she's great i think she has her own like
twitter instagram page where she does
when she does competitive shooting i was
thinking oh wait wait wait look there
was an update on the story says many
people have objected to my use of the
term ptsd in the above story
the use of this term was in no way to
conflate my very temporary anxiety
with the very real condition experienced
by many of our brave men and women in
uniform
i regret the inarticulate use of the
term to describe my in the moment
impression of the gun's firepower
and apologize for it i have also posted
a follow-up piece here oh did he
that's exactly what it meant he says
that's not what i meant that's exactly
what he said he was terrified
to gun lovers you can't even have an
opinion on assault rifles unless it's
theirs here's the proof
bro he okay he says the gun debate is
over when's his article from
it's from june 15 2016. in all my years
in journalism
coming up on 30 i have never received so
much angry mail as i did after
yesterday's story
what it's like to fire an ar-15 bro it's
because you
take a turkey hunting listen if you were
hunting
pheasants or squirrels there would be a
bigger recoil than your ar-15
that's the craziest thing i've asked all
these dudes who are like we're at the
range and i'm like what do you think and
they're like that guy's nuts
like what's the what's the weakest
possible interpretation of using a gun
hunting squirrel and he's gonna have
he's gonna have like game load our bird
shot and he's going to be facing
more pain he's on train too so it's like
what it's like
to to hit a baseball that's being thrown
100 miles an hour from someone that's
untrained it's going to be terrifying
they might get hit by the ball it might
break
in can we take you shooting yeah sure
let's go
let's go this weekend and i think he's
in the bin shooting he fired he fired
the 410 out of the governor uh
oh yeah together yeah you fired the
shotgun shells right yeah
so the it's not like a big shotgun shell
but 410 more out of the the revolver
it's it's it's you know it's it's pretty
big i'd say it's way
way i thought it was going to be way
more kickback than what it was if you're
prepared for it and you have a grip
and you're focused it's not it's very
easy doesn't this tell you how
out of touch journalists are with the
people they cover it would be so
interesting to go into one of these
newsrooms and actually if you could get
them to be honest right the daily news
the new york times
how many people own a gun and actually
know the true answer to that
how many voted for a republican maybe
there's like a janitor there
you know what i mean to see how many
people have you how many of you go to
church
how many of you uh are pro-life any of
these issues where it's like the public
is split but the institutions that cover
them
are so dominated by one side how can
anyone think even if they were
well-intentioned which i don't really
believe anymore
even if they were well-intentioned i
don't see how they could cover a
population like that
the funny thing is they say this and
they acknowledge this
in terms of diversity on the skin
surface level they're saying a
nose room with no black people can't
cover america fairly which
maybe that's not true but they at least
acknowledge it in that capacity
they don't acknowledge the same thing
for actual ideas and actual perspectives
and
experiences you reminded me of that
huffington post picture where they took
a photo of of their editorial board and
one day it was all women
it was just a whole bunch of white women
and everyone's like look at how diverse
we are and i'm like wait what are you
well no no they said they said it was it
was something like what do you notice
about our
oh yeah yeah yeah and it was like a
bunch of women it was all women and then
someone was like there's there's it's
all white people
they're like huffington posts and hire
black people and they had to like
apologize or something oh wait actually
that reminds me of something huffington
post opinion i think it was
actually publicly they released so i
used to pitch up ads in a job that i was
in
and the editor there released like data
about the percentage of minority authors
we published the percentage of trans
authors that we published and they
promised to do better
next year they're like we will actively
ensure that we publish more black people
more trans people and it's like so
you're just openly admitting that you're
not going to publish the best articles
you're going to ask people so are you
trans by the way i need to know so i
can know whether to run this really
great op-ed but um
who do you like banging right uh can you
publish my opinion i don't know do you
like dick or do you like it
like the quality of outcome versus the
equality of opportunity so like if they
publish
more people that created a love of all
humans to work together
as opposed to published more black
people and more women that maybe would
even cause
divert like diversion you know cause
what would you call it like hate i don't
even think of the word because i don't
like it in my
lexicon yeah division so you could have
a bunch of white guys that create
a a space where everyone comes together
or you could have a black guy and a
white woman and a an
african or whatever all creating a
situation where people hate each other
it doesn't matter who they are they're
never going to publish enrique tario
when they say they want more black
writers they're not talking about
enrique or candace owens or the hodge
twins they're talking about
social justice activists who agree with
them when they're talking about
diversity
they're not talking about bringing on
people with different ideas they're
talking about people who look different
but have the exact same ideas
well and if they don't have the same
ideas then you ain't black
right yes that's joe biden for you right
so it's not it's not only just
or it's like peter thiel right the lgbt
media wrote about him that he's not
actually a gay man
he just has sex with other men because
he endorsed trump
dude that's literally an article that
was published
in the advocate uh which is supposed to
be a gay rights magazine
it's it's the the the look saying double
standard hypocrisy has become redundant
at this point
it's something special and new it's just
like
what's the what's what's a you you have
logic and you have like math
and you have formula what's the opposite
like abstract absurdity absurdism
you know it's it's articles that are
meant to make no sense on purpose
you know it's like it's like the art you
know when you look at art it's like you
have like a beauty like we
have we have a picture over there and
it's like a beautiful like aurora
borealis and there's a lake
and that's like a real thing you know
realism
and then what's what's what's the art
called where the abstract yeah abstract
all right that's what it is it's
abstract
it's abstract politics right it's
meaningless and it's meant to be like
that's not possible a possible thing
your ideas are nonsensical
they're like perfect there are perfect
little establishment slave nannies that
are used to push the agenda and the
narrative of controlling people and
getting rid of people's freedoms
and they use it over issues and they use
it over these talking points and these
buzzwords that absolutely have no
meaning just like in 1984
orwellian double speak is becoming more
and more of a reality
yes yes but look what people do with
freedom in new york they bought
too large of sodas so michael bloomberg
had to put a punitive tax on it so that
people would stop buying
too large of some michael bloomberg used
his freedom to put a ban on other
people's sodas
yes yeah see you're trying to curtail
michael bloomberg's freedom
that sob had me arrested i have a long
history with him by the way uh
he's a dirty dirty politician he
promised to help out the first
responders and
the 911 first responders police officers
firefighters medics military men who
were sick and dying after 9 11 told me
hey
he's promising to to give us this
funding and support this bill if you
personally luke stop
harassing him what and confronting him
yeah yeah i don't know if you want to
get into this story but i
i every time he did a radio show every
time he did a ribbon cup
cutting every time he did a gala every
time he did a public event i was on him
like white on rice
confronting him and asking him like
you're cutting support he said that
first responders were sick because of
ptsd and not the actual
uh you know um what was it uh that that
dust that created
us asbestos yeah yeah yeah he said is oh
it's not the asbestos in the air that's
that's hurting all these
first responders and rescue workers it's
ptsd there was there
it's psychosomatic you can't breathe did
i work there no trust me there was there
was a police officer who died that he
called the not a hero james sedroga
and i was on him i was like what are you
doing cutting funding from
these incredibly important individuals
that came to new york city on 911 at
ground zero to rescue people
and now they're being even denied basic
health benefits that they had in their
contract
so i was on bloomberg because i knew
many of these guys a lot of people some
of my friends a lot of them
bloomberg never funded it a first
responder organization came to me
the john field good foundation and they
said look luke we just got a call from
the mayor's office
he's telling us that bloomberg is
running for a re-election we
he wants you to stop questioning him at
every press conference he wants you to
stop
calling into all of his radio shows if
you leave him alone
for his re-election he will give us this
bill right
uh i did and i went to other gala events
and i covered other uh
you know book signings other ribbon
cuttings where he was at i just kind of
gave him a side eye but i didn't do
anything
and i kept my word to the first
responders even though i told him that
bloomberg was going to lie
bloomberg gets reelected for a third
term one of the first thing he does is
he cuts medical benefits for
thousands of 911 first responders uh
they call me back this
particular organization they're like
luke he lied he screwed us over
i'm like i told you so imagine i went to
confront him and literally they had nypd
intelligence a specific branch waiting
for me
as i'm going up the escalator to one of
the gala events and then like radowski
you're coming with us i'm like what no
i'm not uh i'm going outside
they grabbed me held me down i'm like i
want to go i want to leave they're like
no you're not leaving they came back
with 15 police officers
and they said luke we told you to leave
why didn't you leave i'm like yeah i got
it here on camera that you told
that you told me i can't leave took away
the camera threw me in jail
the police officers were fans so they
they were literally like taking me out
and giving me smokes and out of the jail
sale
nypd intelligence came down made sure to
send me down to central bookings for
three days
wow during the weekend even though it
was a criminal trespassing charge that
went on for
two years found non-innocent but that
was one of the reasons that the canadian
government
used to ban me from canada for 10 years
because they said i
had a criminal arrest work so according
to the fbi what you're saying is that
you confessed to committing a crime
no uh i didn't commit anything but um
you know the
the the you know i was never found
guilty they dropped the charges
interesting but uh bloomberg is one of
the dirtiest nastiest politicians and
it's not crazy the democrats are fine
with it because he gives them money
like when he ran for president people
finally talked about it a little but
mostly conservatives this dude has the
longest history of racism
and sexism and me too and misogyny i
mean he literally did the stop in fresco
was like all right you look black get up
against the wall let the police
violate your civil liberties there's a
recording of him arguing with people
about
why how it's right to racially profile
right and this guy was running on the
democratic ticket he had support
yes because he had the checks that's
really it's it's a
surface level commitment to all of this
diversity stuff because ultimately they
knew
that they needed him to beat trump so
they decided whatever all our standards
are flexible
it's amazing that he he like look there
are arguments for
stop and frisk i don't agree i think
it's a fourth amendment violation
but there are arguments about you go
where the crime is i've heard that
before it's like well if there's crime
happening there then we go there try and
stop it
he didn't even do that like there's an
actual argument people say like well
where are they supposed to go to the
wealthiers no bloomberg literally said
but that's what the criminals look like
oh dude
what i mean i was in new york city
during stop and frisk and there was
a number of occasions where even i was
grabbed up thrown against the wall by
some disrespectful nypd officers that
were rude that were antagonizing
i got beat up by them uh you know
previously before on a separate incident
when i was younger
and they just they just again just came
up on you and they started grabbing you
all in your personal
you know parts and i can't even describe
what they they did
you know a number of instances but this
is the this is what they were trying to
normalize government agents walking up
to you on the street as you're doing
your business
and throwing you against your wall
insulting you and putting your
their hands down your pants that's crazy
because if that had gotten federal
traction i mean that's like
massively totalitarian yeah but that's
what these elitists that's what a lot of
these billionaires that's why a lot of
these people
call for that's what they want because
it gives them ultimate power
it gives them something that of course
they can't get enough of just like money
it's it's a it's it's you know like
people
reach a certain level where they have so
much money they they only could focus on
having more money no matter how much
they have
so the same goes for power it's it's an
addictive substance just like attention
is
and it's something that needs to be
addressed against these megalomaniac
psychopaths which are
in washington dc let's talk about
government
power spending with this next story from
the daily mail
revealed fauci is america's highest paid
federal employee on 417
608 salary after joking in interview
with matt mcconaughey
that he was just a government worker on
a government salary
so uh how do i get one of those
government salaries gosh
they say fauci is the nation's highest
paid federal employee raking in
417 000 in 2019 which is the latest year
that federal salary date is available
he made more than the president's four
hundred thousand dollar
a year salary excuse me in 2019 he also
made more than mike pence who outranks
fauci in authority and made 235
dollars in salary as well as dr deborah
burks who made three hundred and five
thousand
if fauci remains in this position and
doesn't get a raise he'll make 2.5
million dollars
from 2019 through 2024 i don't know why
they picked those years but i guess it's
because of the next term
data shows that the highest federal
employees were medical and dental
officers
why are we paying look look you can talk
about dr fauci
and his right or wrong and lockdowns and
all stuff but why are we paying these
people so much money
it's not just about fauci it's about
just all of these people in general
getting
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
the taxpayer
for what the because they're friends
with the people that make the rules
that dole out the finance and it's free
money for them because it's tax money
they don't have to know
us yep to take our money they just get
it so that's funny though because i'm
actually i thought those numbers would
be even worse
because at the state and local level
like at the university level
a university president at least at where
i went umass
makes north of six hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
right the basketball coach at umass
which sucked and lost
most of its games made a million dollars
when i was there he made more than the
president
and these are all government employees
made more than the governor of
massachusetts the public
yeah they're all these are all
taxpayer-funded and so
if you listen if you can't succeed in
business
go to government and because they
actually the funny thing about
government is how they advance and how
they do raises
is not based on merit it's literally
just basically all right all right
i'll say this tax money going to
these people to pay them exorbitant
salaries is theft
yeah there we go i've been working on
you for a while
we did it folks let's celebrate
i think the idea of taxing is fine the
problem is when the government's corrupt
then it's not being used for what it's
supposed to be it's supposed to be used
for
you can make all these argument all the
margins in the world from the left about
taxes are good it's like paying a
subscription to receive the roads
and the safety and the clean water and
i'm like sure if that's what it was used
for
am i supposed look i got no problem with
taxes the prop the pro i have no
practice with the concept of paying
taxes the problem i have is
how much is going to blow up kids how
much is going to pay this this dude's
salary for the basketball team which
this point
like what's why are you getting a
million dollars but that's the thing is
in concept that makes sense but
government is
always going to be corrupt show me the
government that isn't corrupt government
power centralized power by its very
nature
corrupts even good people though good
people are usually not drawn to high
office and running for power it this is
public choice theory
in economics it self selects for the
people that are the most ambitious
and most ruthless they're the only ones
that can get to the top of the food
chain so
government corruption is not a bug it is
the system
yeah very good point that you made there
now there are some people arguing that
we should pay
politicians and government officials a
high amount so they don't get bribed by
special interests
not but but this definitely seems
exorbitant to say the least
uh dr fauci i mean i'm definitely not a
fan of him uh
especially everything he did at the
wuhan laboratory
specifically trying to make coronavirus
as lethal as it could be with the gain
of function data studies
uh but you know there there is an
argument to be made that you don't want
these people working for other interests
but as i've been
arguing against that saying you know
money uh corrupts individuals and you
never have enough so
even if you do pay them a lot you know
what's the middle ground here where do
we meet in the middle
uh to make sure that they're satisfied
and that they're not corrupt because i
mean
essentially let's let's ask ourselves
what what did dr fauci do
i mean he's repeating a lot of the world
health organization kind of directives
and talking points but those keep
flip-flopping all the time
a lot of the projections were wrong i
think it's very fair to say that the
united states handling of this entire
situation has been extremely
poor so when you have something that is
not done right
you shouldn't be paying top dollar for
it well and that's the problem is with
businesses if they mess up and they then
guess what they go
under business or if an employee messes
up big time they get fired but think
about it like this the cdc
literally blocked all coveted testing at
the beginning and said only you can only
use our test
right but then their test didn't work
and it took them months before they
allowed private labs
to go and make tests again the cdc did
not lose any money from their budget
from that
exactly they didn't get cut they didn't
get shrunk like a private business that
bombed that bad would probably go out of
business or
boycott it or even dr fauci that told
you that masks are bad
that you shouldn't wear masks dr fauci
literally was telling you that
flip-flopping all the time under the
directives of the world health
organization which he
just a couple days ago was very excited
that the united states is going to be
back a part of and financing and funding
even though they don't even recognize
taiwan as a country which is absolutely
ridiculous we also have to talk about
the
the fouchy fetish like the media and
some of the liberals
not like some people just like him right
but some people have gotten like culty
with it yeah like they have like fouchy
i've seen fouchy sex toys yes
i've seen like glowing profiles of him
about how he's like a stud and a
and all these memes that are like sort
of joking sexualization
screws you over literally and
figuratively
you guys sense this like cult worship
we're like who's the new
it's like greta thundberg 2.0 who's
who's the new celebrity it's
uh this guy fauci they're like oh it's
this guy
let's oh no now it's kamala harris let's
let's worship
kamala here well to be fair brad pitt
did play dr fauci
on snl good for him so i mean if if
you're looking at those kind of
accreditations you don't have much
accreditation what did dr fauci do
during this entire saga that we've been
through that actually made a positive
impact into
the coronavirus i mean that's a serious
legitimate question that we need to be
asking especially if he's getting paid
that much i mean can you name anything
noble or great that he's done with the
coronavirus other than just repeat world
health organization talking points and
and contradict himself all the time well
we don't know what he's done behind the
scenes
and i i imagine he seems like a good guy
i think he's done his best and it was
like a
super horrible position to be in right
no one knew how to handle it but no one
can say he didn't make a ton of mistakes
he
he did and we should be allowed to point
those out and ask
what the consequences are yeah is there
going to be any accountability is there
going to be
any way to uh get you know
justice for some of the larger
consequences that are leading
because of very bad government mistakes
well so here's the thing that bothers me
the most about fauci and some of these
other public health people is they were
saying they changed their tune and they
act like they never did
so for example you mentioned masks and
that's a good one but also schools
yeah schools rand paul and a bunch of
other people and science was showing
this to in other countries
that reopening schools was perfectly
safe and fine and fauci
and other people were totally against it
and then they just pivoted
a month or two ago they've really
pivoted hardcore since the election and
about lockdowns and that's what i can't
stand is it i feel a little gas-lit by
it all
yep you may have heard some chiming i
don't know if that was coming through in
the podcast but it's because
i was scouring the web to try and find
that story about fauci and the research
and i got it to newsweek.com
dr fauci backed controversial wuhan lab
with us dollars for risky coronavirus
research
his newsweek how have i never heard that
this is newsweek that tells you that a
lot that i've never heard that story
from april 28th of last year
they say dr fauci is an advisor to trump
last year the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases led by
fauci
funded scientists at the wuhan institute
of virology and other institutions
for work on gain of function research on
bat coronaviruses
what it what's well the particular the
particular bats that are in question
here that many scientists and experts
point to uh leading to the coronavirus
are thousands of miles away from wuhan
so the possibility of these bats
traveling specifically to
wuhan is extremely improbable now do we
have any empirical evidence showing that
there's a direct
link to this no there's a crap ton of
circumstantial evidence highlighting
exactly
that there could have been an accidental
okay people were selling them
people were taking animals to the wet
markets that's what they're saying
there is from i think new york mag what
they call the lab league hypothesis
we don't know for sure exactly we don't
know for sure but there is a lot of
circumstantial evidence that a lot of
experts are looking at and pointing to
and saying
they were literally working on making
the coronavirus
jump uh from species to species making
it as dangerous as possible
uh this is where the term gain of
function comes from this is
what dr fauci was literally in charge of
bankrolling
uh you know before the coronavirus so
this is in the united states there was
even diplomatic leaked cables
saying that there's a high probability
of a virus leaking
from this wuhan laboratory before the
coronavirus
and just to clarify this is from the
intelligence or new york mag the lab
leak hypothesis for decades scientists
have been hot-wiring viruses
in hopes of preventing a pandemic not
causing one but what if
and that's basically what he brings up
that there are many scientists saying
that
essentially the hypothesis is they were
trying to create vaccines
and then there was a breach of some sort
but i'm not saying that's true
if you read it in the new york mag take
it from them beloved sometimes you need
a crisis
man we couldn't get into syria the the
weapons of mass destruction weren't
quite enough
you know 9 11 got people riled up but
there has a vacuuming
yeah just to rally everyone to become
subservient you know soldiers or
for the cause or whatever well the
reason this is important to me because
if if we could understand the origin of
this sickness we could deal with it
so the real issue right now is china
blocking the world health organization
or the researchers who want to come in
around a year china has blocked the
world health organization the world
health organization that sings its
praises that says that
china did an amazing job with the
coronavirus they
are even being blocked from coming in
and just a few days ago
finally after i believe three or four
official very public
uh attempts that china grant the world
health health organization access into
the supposed wet market
well china re-opened the wet markets yes
that's
the craziest part about all of this
these wet markers are notoriously
unhygienic and dangerous for diseases
and jumping and this happened
came coming from one it was at least the
original hypothesis
they reopened them they don't they
evidently don't care and another thing
that bothers me actually as a journalist
is i see all the time
china's numbers just uncritically
parroted like the headline will be
china new crate case numbers hazkovit
under control
or china's economic numbers i'm
particularly suspicious of they're like
rosy economy in china as a rest of world
struggles
and i'm like you're just repeating
according to communist party officials
um well hold on you just said you're not
gonna question that
you think that those are just
trustworthy figures you can just
accept as fact think about how many
journalists in the united states
all of a sudden became the cheerleaders
for the u.s intelligence apparatus when
donald trump got elected all of a sudden
everything the government said was true
and correct all the time how many
leftists made that switch too
they're like and also they were kind of
right like decades ago saying like the
war on terror
they're infringing civil liberties and
then it was like oh they're spying on
trump
heck yeah like well that's okay
now it's really funny because you got
some lefties who are like you know
we mentioned the journalists with
sending the troops how dare you then
they send in the troops to dc that's a
good thing and there's a good reason for
it
and they're keeping them there up until
march or maybe even indefinitely because
of a supposed
threat again the threat it's the
impeachment trial what did jack bosobic
say he's like uh the military will
will remain occupying the city until the
opposition leader's trial is is over
that's just absolutely crazy so i
actually went i actually went into the
city when this was all locked down and
everything and i had to like get an
uber to go somewhere to do something for
my job right and he could only get me
within a mile to where i needed to go
because there was like
swat team not even swat teams but like
military trucks
blocking the road and put up fences and
i had to walk the rest of the way like
just get the uber
i got the uber like within a mile and i
was like i guess i'll just walk
what day was that oh that was like two
days before inauguration
uh it wasn't on inauguration day and it
wasn't even particularly close to the
capitol or anything it was like a couple
miles from there
have they toned down the security
somewhat but so they reopened the
highways and they reopened the bridges
they literally closed the bridges from
arlington
to the dc like you just couldn't go
across and i was like
how are people who are essential workers
supposed to
do that this whole this the shutting
down of the economy in the world is is
really
kind of crazy i was my conspiratorial
mind is like
lit up the last few days particularly
the last few days for some reason
thinking about
wuhan and corona because obviously
corona is nasty
but where it came from totally up for
debate and
we should talk about it because
bioweapons we've been making movies
about them for 20 years and it's like
it is a terrifying idea i just i just
think it's so
disruptive to the world economy i mean
it's just listen grinding things to us
you're confusing the virus with the
government well i'm thinking of
yeah i'm thinking of the response to the
virus what i'm most concerned with right
what we know about covet is a 99.99
survival rate for people under what 70
70 years old yeah so it's it's question
the question is the government response
rate
now they're they're they're adjusting
the pcr test threshold that was the
world health organization that even
it's not it's look you know people have
gotten sick
i know people who have gotten sick with
it and i know and and i know people who
have
had family members die with it right i
think the reality is never let a good
crisis go to waste
it's just simple it's the government saw
an opportunity to exploit us because
there was something happening so like
well
and government also they they never
think of the unintended consequences
right so they see the problem they swing
the hammer
but it's like i saw a study the other
day actually and this was in the
national bureau of economic research
saying that eight hundred and fifty
thousand excess deaths will be caused
from the covid related unemployment
and that's mostly from the lockdowns not
from the disease what is that like in
in a over a year over the next 15 years
from on
from suicides from uh depression from
heart issues
like this isn't documented trend in
economics that unemployment causes
health issues poverty causes health
issues and so and that's just one thing
yeah
that's not counting suicide
uh marital violence and domestic
violence and the children of all the
people that that will affect so if 850
000 people
are are going to kill themselves or die
what about all their kids
right there's another 16 million people
yeah but it's all these second order
unintended consequences when they just
looked at one thing and they didn't
consider anything else and then they
refused to adapt
also that's the original i think the
original mistake you have to give some
grace for what's bothered me is the fact
that they've doubled down on failed
tactics they haven't adapted
and they got promoted for it and never
held accountable for it the other study
that i saw was done by duke harvard and
john
john hopkins uh professors and they
talked about an excess of one million
debts
coming in the future because of the
longer effects of these
lockdowns and again that's not even
including the health screenings
the stoppage of cancer treatments mental
health illnesses
and a large number of economic illnesses
that are going to be happening as of
course people have to deal with the
larger consequences of a failing economy
losing their jobs losing their
businesses
and having failing wages with just
record medical care don't forget the
kids
who have lost school and have it shut
down they will this will
like you you will look back at the
trends 10 years from now and you'll see
like a distinct
class of children who were screwed over
by this and it will show in their
lifetime success because you can't miss
a year and a half of school and just
that's fine
a lot of these kids are committing
suicide or at least trying to i saw a
terrifying story about that about a
school that reopened i can't remember
the details but a school that reopened
because it had a suicide spike among its
students and they're like we have to
reopen this was a private school and
you can't do this to kids especially
when they're we're also transferring it
because
they're not the ones at risk here at all
and so we're transferring the cost
to them for the benefits for other
subsets of society i think that's funny
maybe because there's been even some
studies showing that there's no benefit
towards lockdowns and that lockdowns
actually may create
certain situations where people
accumulate together at walmart or
target or costco and therefore could
even help spread
the sickness even further so there's
even medical there's showing
that lockdowns don't work and part of it
is this right so i got really frustrated
by new york city and
and uh cuomo he ordered restaurants to
close they were at 25
capacity they were getting some people
could go to restaurants but it was
limited it was
super safety measures but the state's
own data showed that only 1.4 percent of
covid cases were coming from restaurants
most covet cases were coming from
private interpersonal household
gatherings
well guess what happens when you shut
down the restaurants people have more
gatherings
like these people actually made this
worse by shutting down businesses so not
only did they slap
new york entrepreneurs in the face but
they also probably made covetours
you also see riots breaking out which is
talking about destroying people's lives
this capital riot
maybe it would have happened if there
was no corona probably not it fuels them
yeah people wouldn't be out screaming
destroying emotion if
they weren't forced to stay inside and
losing their money and their income
trump would have won if there was no
corona so not a bad argument that's a
that's a good shot yeah i mean
but he also would have won if he handled
it better it's true yeah he had an
opportunity
and you know interestingly trump relied
too much on fauci
for whatever reason fauci you know what
i saw him doing was basically the media
would say it a day later he'd repeat it
and that's why he ended up being wrong
so often he'd say things like oh you
shouldn't wear a mask and then two days
later
oh yeah you should wear a mask and it's
like bro they were saying that in the
news like two days ago
so the dude in my opinion for a while i
was like i like fauci he seems to be on
the level seems to be keeping a surprise
to things and then
then it kind of felt like wait a minute
this guy's like checked out isn't he
he's like super old he's been there for
decades to get a hundred thousand
dollars a year he's just sitting back on
like what are they saying cnn
are his eyes at half-mast because he's
zen or because he's on drugs
[Laughter]
neither he's because he's checked out
he's like this like dude
he recently made a statement talking
about how the numbers are plateauing and
everything
seems very promising in the united
states moving forward with covid was
this after the election
yes well also michigan dc chicago
california new york all of the
political leadership are making
announcements that they're reopening
easing
restrictions it's just a coincidence
it's just you know it could be
how many how many states was that again
how many cities uh well there's uh
there's uh dc
the state of michigan the city of
chicago california and new york the real
numbers that's the only thing that's
even when the powerball it's only like
half the
country's population yeah the state of
the new york centers
you know the state of new york but but
again let's be open-minded
could be a coincidence probability who
knows let's you know
we could we could play those games at
all but but i think it's important to
have all those possibilities open
but i i agree with your shout though
like trump definitely
would have won if covet hadn't happened
because before then people were talking
about the election in terms of socialism
versus not
woke-ism versus knowledge and the
economy in the economy
right but then covet it really all
became about competence and stability
and those are not trump's strong suits
those are not government's strong suits
at all when when trump was giving his
daily briefings he reached his
all-time approval rating in aggregate
and then also the media panicked and
then stopped airing them saying he was
lying too much
what really happened in my opinion was
not whether or not trump did a good or
bad job it was that no matter what
happened the media said it was a bad job
now you have joe biden coming out saying
in his recent speech there's nothing we
can do
about the trajectory of covet at this
point when he said he was going to shut
it down
right while he was campaigning no no
he's like there's nothing we can do well
he hit a plan
he said last year the travel ban won't
do anything now he's just reinstated a
travel ban you know people in south
africa right
and she's actually valid but that's
actually valid i'm pretty sure and
europe another
other it's the same travel ban trump
lifted in the first place he's doing
more travel bans
he added more countries i i we we've
talked with lefties about this and i
said
you know basically by what metric do you
compare trump's job on the corona virus
if we were looking at the media trump
did a tremendous job because they were
saying millions would die and then
hundreds of thousands have died
and that's why conservatives republicans
when polled were like we're hap we're
okay with where things are
because they were told it was going to
be 90 you know 90 percent higher
one to two million was there i'm sorry
like 10 times higher
and then it was one or two million and
then it ended up being like 100 to 200
000 and people were like wow we were
warned that it was gonna be worse trump
must have done a good job
but the left just said no all these
people are dead it's the worst possible
job ignore that
no matter what he did it was wrong and
that's and then people
people believe it that's just it and tr
you know trump's problem is he does have
he did have a direct line to the people
with twitter but boy did he not know how
to use it
look he tweeted and it and it's
something we've seen other people do
but he didn't do it as effectively as he
could or should have
so the message was jack dorsey can i
send this message message jack dorsey
can i send this message
no he was saying can i send this instead
of every time you tweet you're asking
jack dorsey if you're allowed to send
that message
the issue is that trump would like
attack people and he would play he'll
get caught into the flame war
and that's always been his problem right
a lot of people liked it but he had an
opportunity to bypass the press and they
hated him for it
and he did many times but too often it
was just
inflammatory you know internet flame i
was listening to some guy last night
that worked with him a lot and said that
he was a raging adderall addict
in the 80s and 90s like just a party boy
going to have
adderall in the 80s and 90s speed
different kinds of it's a
methamphetamine i don't know about we
don't know
but no today like obviously he
supposedly doesn't even take alcohol
yeah according to him he never doesn't
touch drugs at all but they had to
remove the diet coke button from the
white house
he had a i wouldn't want to die
the substance i know i know people who
have changed iced coffee
i know people have been on this on on
the plane with him covering stories and
stuff
and they tell me the dude doesn't do
drugs he doesn't drink
and he only eats mcdonald's i never saw
him do drugs so he doesn't ever do them
what a moronic statement that
journalists who've actually been with
them i spent some time with him and he
didn't do it so he never does it
like what the hell when when journalists
are flying around with him and following
him on his
on his on his campaign tours never see
him put a drink or dude
the people that work with him he was a
just look up that story and look up that
thing but the media was hyper critical
if the man had toilet paper on his shoe
if he had two scoops of ice cream they
had a
crap storm about that so if they if he
had a drug problem i think they would
have found out about it and talked about
it
and and i definitely agree with your
point here tim he could have spent his
time
better because you know dunking on rosie
o'donnell maybe
is not the priority and shouldn't be the
priority when it comes to the issues
that this country is facing
so you know well and most leaders most
politicians actually got an approval
bounce
except for trump every governor like
everyone except for trump and i think
there's two reasons for that one i think
you're right is the media but two is how
he handled it and how he
he did shoot himself in the foot on
several occasions with stuff he said or
feuds he started
that's always been part of his problem
it's you know he started his campaign
with being this
this this character and and you know and
and being very negative on a bunch of
different things playing to the internet
and he's been that way for a long time
even before he was running
he was tweeting things about obama and
rosie o'donnell
and so what happens is he enters office
with this perception that the media
used and exploited to make money and
there was very little he could do
because people
already hated him that was it the guy's
name is noel casler
he worked in the entertainment industry
in like the 90s 2000s running for shows
and but i think when trump says what did
he do with trump
uh he worked on the apprentice uh he
would he'd be the guy that worked
between the producer
and the actors so that the producers
didn't have to tell the actors like hey
what time are you gonna be here what do
you need
he would do all that stuff for the
production company so they'd hire him
and bring him into different shows
um he worked like michael jackson
madonna and trump
and i think when trump says i don't do
drugs he's saying
i don't do illegal drugs and he got an
adderall
um prescription could be we don't know
uh but but another thing to kind of
really think about here
is that when he first even became
president four years ago we were
literally
arguing about crowd sizes donald trump
was saying he had the biggest crowd way
bigger than barack obama and at that
point i knew
there was an ego problem and when
someone has an ego problem they could be
very easily manipulated and that's when
i knew
this is not going to be the four years
that he promises it's going to be
because
a lot of people could just pull a couple
strings here and there especially with
someone
is very statistical yep and they could
they could easily get their way
with someone who's so full of themselves
the bomb stock ban was a perfect example
of how democrats could have manipulated
trump way better if they wanted to
if they just sucked up to him they could
have got him he does not have except for
a few issues
rooted core values so he's very subject
to influence by you know who the last
person that talked to
who kissed up to him the most so that's
that was always the problem that's how
people like john bolton got in that
administration
nola was saying that he also got this
like nasal plasty um
surgery to get this part of his nose
reconstructed from all the cocaine he
did that blew out his
the cartilage in his nose like he was a
party boy
in his early days just women women drugs
he was seen with jeffrey epstein
partying it up um
him and bill yeah bill clinton what yep
it's so funny that he comes out and he's
like i never touched drugs and he acts
with this like
piety when he's like dude that guy was
crazy
i don't know it's hard to it's hard to
um you really determine that especially
from one person
i would understand if there was a number
of people and maybe if there was some
evidence but
until there's evidence or actually other
people collaborating i don't think it's
good to take that
right right i don't even dog on drugs
i'm all about i just don't care
yeah the reason but don't lie about it
the reason i don't buy it is because
when you google search the story
it's a bunch of people speculating that
trump was sniffling and they're like i
watched a video we're trying by the
sniffles that proves it on drugs
there's a bunch of articles speculating
and then what i know about trump because
i've known journalists who have been on
his beat is that he's a
complete germaphobe he won't touch
people he doesn't like shaking people's
hands he's always
doing sanitizer and he only eats at fast
food restaurants because he's scared
about getting something foreign in his
food
and he believes that that mcdonald's has
universal standards
so if he orders pre-made food he's safe
so like you walk in mcdonald's say give
me that burger right there they couldn't
have put something in it and he can't
get sick from
it it's a combination of i guess a fear
of poisonings and also a fear that
smaller restaurants have you don't know
if they're going to be following some
specific code for cleanliness
so he only eats vegetables why is a
photo of him on the plane with fast food
and so the people i i the journalists i
know who have been on the plane with him
and and followed his entire campaign
tour
uh for both terms have said basically
the dude is like straight edge
maybe he's not i believe that with
alcohol because at the very least about
alcohol
because with alcohol is i believe it was
his brother that died
and was an alcoholic and from what i've
heard that's very genuine that he
doesn't drink he has no signs of
alcoholism at all
but it's not even me it's like it's not
even a positive story to say he's a
germaphobe who only
eats mcdonald's it's just weird that i
see all these stories popping up trying
to claim that he does drugs because they
saw him sniffling or because people have
accused him of doing it
there was one story where they claimed
he was getting prescribed some kind of
medication
to help him like be active and alert and
awake federal i don't think it was
adderall but
there was a story about it and that was
as close as we got to
is donald trump doing drugs but so you
mentioned mcdonald's the best moment of
his presidency was when he had the whole
chick-fil-a
yeah i forget the exact circumstances
but there were some guests coming to the
white house and they could and there was
some issue with the kitchen or the food
they were going to prepare so we got
full
chick-fil-a spread for them all
chick-fil-a is good man let's read super
chats everybody
if you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the notification
bell and go to timcast.com
become a member we're gonna have some
more bonus segments coming up and we're
actually
doing a lot more bonus segments that are
more probably got to the gun range and
stuff like that
maybe some kind of behind the scenes
stuff that being said let's read
karma and kerosene says they have
dropped a more anti-leftist pop culture
yesterday
our new single compromised about joe
biden come check it out after the stream
sounds cool will do yeah so that's one
of the things that i've talked about
conservatives and people on the right
spend too much time
complaining about things and so there's
really got to be an effort to produce
things you know like do stuff play music
play video games did you hear about the
daily wire launching their own movie
yes i like that yep i'm going to be
watching it and actually i'm going to be
interviewing
is pretty good for the the producer for
my podcast right but they
actually are going into the cultural
arena and i respect that because
the culture is where the battles are
originally won and then
politics is downstream and it's like
like sun tzu said you have to win the
war before you fight it
right well that's a paraphrasing because
the actual quotes probably more profound
than that but you get the idea
all right we got east f says crowders
having twins having heart complications
and launching a lawsuit
he posted an update today going back
coming back february first i did watch
his video
heartbroken glad to hear it what lawsuit
wow oh no he seems young though
yeah he's uh i think he's younger than i
am i think he's stressed
that's crazy yeah it happens i think he
said it was genetic
genetic issue so i hope he's doing all
right hope help will be okay come back
when you feel all right buddy twins is a
nice move
yeah there you go soft shell crab
says i wanted to ask who's y'all's
favorite commander to play also mano red
for the win
yeah look at tim did you see tim's face
when i said that we basically banned
urzah
oh um monored is for the win it wins so
often
but um who do i like playing the most
now probably
um i don't know oh nurse that's pretty
funny yeah
because it's just crazy yeah he's cool
yeah i wish you guys played cards most
people are like no idea what you're
talking about
i have no idea yeah matches the
gathering no no no sorry it's a card
game
oh i know what it is oh i just died
don't play gage kemper says hey tim and
ian check out the new treasury secretary
on her stance on crypto
article on business insider from january
20th push for new harsh regulations
coming of cryptocurrency yep i've seen
that
we'll see though when you got massive
special interest and all these big
corporations supporting it and investing
in it they're not gonna let
yellen come after their investment well
she actually walked it back a little bit
too so she put out a statement because
uh bitcoin dropped after
she said that of course but she put out
a statement later that was kind of
saying uh
actually not so bad i don't know so
they're just creating a buying
opportunity and what did what did you
expect from the former someone check her
bank account
yeah she bought she would let it go down
bought a ton i said i was gonna buy the
dip and people were like you're crazy
it's gonna bottom out then buy and then
it went right back up
yeah the dollar is the ultimate uh crap
coin family-friendly show
all right let's see we got here inside
of the aj says all content be tagged and
a protocol could be built to insert the
original video into your video edits via
time stamp
calling the og file saves space and
gives watch time to both chain of credit
interesting we have to build it's about
like building a video protocol i guess
or blockchain or something
i don't know opulent gaming says i'm
trying very hard not to laugh at all the
people who voted for biden
and are now regretting their vote also
people want to say there wasn't any
voter fraud
but a limestone county woman was
arrested for 134 felony counts
of it and the veritas lady that's the
problem i have with the
the fraud people they try and make it so
that any claim of voter fraud is a grand
conspiracy
when there's literally bill bar on
record saying we've found a bunch of
fraud just enough to change the election
and then you have the veritas lady
getting arrested paxton putting out the
statement the ag like we've arrested
this lady yeah it happens
you know but uh the two side's talking
past each other on that one it's like
one side won't acknowledge any fraud
happen and the other claims that
it would have swung the whole election
rand paul
is smart about he brings up the uh the
correct argument i believe was state
legislatures
uh having having a laws change that
their approval so there was election law
changes by
ag's by by governors
by the constitution any election
election laws have to go through the
legislature
that's the real argument about what's
concerning with this best election
but that never you know got to do we
didn't talk about it but dominion
uh launched a lawsuit against giuliani
for 1.3 billion
that sounds like a fake lawsuit like
they're just they're just pushing
they're just throwing their weight
around because they have money
it's it's the stupidest thing in the
world when a company's like i'm gonna
sue you for
a billion dollars
the giuliani one sounds like a stretch
but i actually think there might be
something to the way they sued newsmax
and some of these other outlets because
those outlets immediately ran massive
retractions
there's this website american thinker
it's like a conservative website
they ran the craziest retraction i've
ever seen
apologizing to dominion saying at no
basis in fact
because dominion told them we won't sue
you if you do this so they must be
scared of something
well i think a lot of people were
pushing conspiracy theories
and you know what man the cue stuff is
just really sad
now there's now they're claiming yeah
it's just it never ends
no matter how often they're wrong it's
become it becomes pseudo-religious
almost
right nightmarishly so like i see gold
fringes on the flag you know and march
4th is the real inauguration it's like
just stop just stop
why do people fall for those things like
why is it that there are good people i
know whose parents
they live in cu i think it's because
people want to feel
like they do have control over their
lives to some degree
and you have two choices either we have
no control in these elections and the
people we want lose
or it's a grand conspiracy against you
and it's easier to believe that
you're fighting this grand fight against
the evil cabal
at least when you're involved in this
grand fight with team q
you're not helpless i guess right you're
not helpless when the alternative is the
system is too big it's out of control
and the guy you didn't want to win you
know won
so people just keep believing it no
matter how much they're wrong
you know without naming anybody i've had
people i've seen people on facebook
saying
you know it was uh on the fifth i think
trump's going to make the announcement
today posting links and showing photos
and showing cue screenshots
and then they're like today's the day
trump's gonna make the announcement
executive order blah blah nothing
happened
then they were like i got it wrong it's
actually tomorrow it's gonna happen just
before the vote announcement
nothing happened well i i don't know
because i don't know what the cue people
you know
what he's doing so and i'm like like the
mind calendar thing yeah it is
just stop it's not happening it's never
happened mueller wasn't working for
trump
they believed that you know that right
they were saying during the
investigation that mueller was secretly
working for trump
yeah it's almost like look man they get
mad at me because
you know because they want to just they
want to believe it they want to believe
it's just not maybe there's some
some threads of truth to queue maybe
no i don't know i'll tell you what it is
but it seems like take bull for the most
part
take a connect the dots do you ever do
connect the dots yes
it's a sailboat and they have a picture
it's a you can you can see the outline
with all the dots a sailboat
but they use the dots to draw a picture
of a dolphin and they're like it's a
dolphin you're like no
you ignored all of this you connected
these dots that shouldn't be connected
yeah
oh okay so the dots are real they're
just not
connected they're connecting the wrong
ones and that's that's what you get from
a lot of conspiracy theorists they'll
see a pattern but then make the
incorrect
assessments over what the connections
are whereas everyone is going one two
three four like a sailboat they're going
like 7
13 5 6 0
and they're getting a weird image no
critical thinking skills on the left on
the right on the conspiracy theorist
we just need to think if you really want
to ban fake news the best way to do it
is to teach people how to think
independently
and to look at evidence and make up
their own minds and decisions i mean if
we really cared about society
we would be doing that what do you what
do you think about q
luke what is there to think about
uh it's it's it's riddles i mean i've
been calling it out it's
been caught out for
and i was saying i need to see evidence
i need to see proof they're saying a lot
of vague
language it doesn't really add up to
anything and
i got attacked i got ridiculed fiora i
knew i knew youtube curators that had
their videos taken down that ridiculed
it
so i i i it it's crazy but how crazy is
it that uh
marjorie taylor green she openly
believes it and she got elected to
congress
yeah this isn't going away i don't
that's the problem with it is i've tried
to
explain why it's not true i've tried to
like share fact checks but there's
something impenetrable here
and i haven't figured it out yet why it
is that this is not going away when
people are presented with the facts that
do not add up to this conspiracy
because they'll have a mental breakdown
because there is
a a characteristic of the human mind
that when it is
when when when our brains solidify
around an idea and this happens to the
left happens the right hands to
everybody
and our what our brains are basically
saying is this is true and correct
and we're surviving because of it right
so you you
you grow up there are certain behaviors
you pick up there's certain things you
believe
and you've succeeded to a certain point
where your brain says
this is how i succeeded and survived if
someone can disprove
those things it puts your life at risk
essentially right so then people have
mental breakdowns and they're confronted
with hard evidence that disproves their
world views
it's kind of like an extreme version of
the fact that somebody who's like made
their life
on a certain belief and made their lives
work
can't have their mind changed because
they have so much invested in it and
they've built their sense of self around
it it's like
an extreme version of that let's read
some more super chats
mark shapcod says tim you say defend
don't act but how did that work for
alexander hamilton
he tried to do the noble thing and died
we got aaron burr he could have just
said i'm not gonna duel you
i mean his dueling was a big thing back
then i guess but yeah
he uh i guess the story is alexander
hamilton purposefully missed you know
missed
because he didn't think it was going to
be alleged duel and he got he got hit in
the chest or whatever and then there you
go he died
but that's like come on matt's like what
200 years ago 100 and something years
ago
also the musical soundtrack slaps
let's see ponyboy says i lean right tim
but i respect you for not succumbing to
the bias of your fan base and sticking
to your research
with all the negativity maybe a good
idea would be to focus on one
wholesome story a week or something well
what we're going to be doing more and
more of is uh
just you know we've got some people who
want to come on the show who focus on
near-death experiences
and life after death and stuff like that
like real research not like some you
know hippie shaman guy who thinks he's
an alien
the one from the capitol not him right
we actually have people who are like
university professors who have done
research on people who have
have had you know near-death experiences
and there's like weird commonalities and
patterns
that's the fun stuff to talk about so
we're definitely planning some shows
maybe fridays
we'll be like welcome to the weekend
we're just going to kind of chill out
and enter the weekend with a smile on
our faces and talk about bigfoot or
something
you know you know there's a congressman
who wrote a whole book about bigfoot a
former congressman now
denver denver riggleman he wrote a whole
uh
book about bigfoot erotica that's very
weird
that's amazing before or after he was in
office so what happened and i'm gonna
butcher this because i don't know the
details but like his
his camp his campaign opponent made some
oppa research
claiming that he liked bigfoot erotica
and he didn't but then he wrote a whole
book about conspiracy theories
and how there are people out there who
believe in bigfoot for real
and who have it's become kind of a
sexual cult i guess
around bigfoot all right and so this
congressman who just left office
published a whole book about it do they
go to burning man
i don't know all right all right let's
read some more intellectual millennials
says growing up i saw the left hate
corporations
and yet with this fight is the dem
supporting corporations
side note i truly believe trump's
stirring brought up multiple trafficking
issues connected with those in
government
where's maxwell i don't know what that
is
and uh the maxwell stuff and epstein
stuff there's a lot of stuff
we we know but i think we're only
scratching the surface
i think i think it's it's it's you know
a lot of people want
i'll just put it this way we probably
know one out of a hundred things about
what's actually going on
and you think about what epstein's been
accused of i think there's way more
going on human trafficking
but i just understand way more than that
there's probably shady business it's
probably drug dealers by
weapons trafficking it's probably all
the craziest stuff you can think of
but yeah but we don't know because all
the secrets went away with
jeffrey epstein yep you know the russia
the russian dissident that just went
back
put out a public statement i am not
suicidal because he knew the russian
government was about to arrest him
i like him oh the guy navalny yes he put
out a statement uh as soon as the
russians were arresting him putin's
people were arresting him
saying i'm not suicidal they just
arrested him again
as soon as he went back they arrested
him yeah he's been injured that's where
all the protests came from this weekend
we have a very important one from jacob
williams he says tim and cast the 50
caliber
or meduse is made by browning the laser
tech for listening to conversations has
been around since the ussr
if you want to see insane things
satellites are capable of look into
maxar as well as a book called deep
black
interesting it'd be fun to have someone
talk about that on the show too like
ancient so
like like cold war technology and crazy
spy stuff that'd be a lot of fun
what were the soviets doing
turk longwell says wait a second did
luke just say that he wants to buy a 50
cal machine gun
y'all get serious down there huh great
guess too rock on not
not a machine gun just a single fire you
know could be semi-auto could be even
bulk
but uh what can which states allow
a machine gun like a legit well machine
guns are banned in some states
uh but most importantly it's they're
only available for the rich if you're
rich you could have one and you just
have to fill
i think a nfa license to get one all
right here we go judo eagle says i feel
bad for the nsa guy assigned to ian
[Laughter]
he loves his life he's sitting there and
he's like he's watching ian just like on
his computer
skating again no no he talks about his
friends dude did you know like this dmt
stuff
what are you talking about i'm just
listening to ian man this is crazy stuff
and now he's like i need mushrooms for
this the nsa guys doing dmt
most undoubtedly all right let's see
i am and sanity says i had a news
channel in 2015 with 100k subs
quit because of death threats try it
again in 2019 but quit when a guy tried
to break into my house at 2am to kill me
luckily live in texas and have a lot of
guns whoa that's crazy
polaris 589 says brad palumbo doesn't
like privately owned tanks
fake phony libertarian you don't like
privately owned tanks how dare you
so my whole thing was i criticized the
libertarian party presidential nominee
for saying that private citizens should
be able to own tanks
because i basically said it's just
totally out of touch it's just like
and i think you have to draw so i'm very
pro-gun but i think you have to draw the
line somewhere
right like i don't believe private nuke
ownership and i think
because that's crazy you think you would
do trust bill gates with a nuke
um i don't think bill gates would nuke
anybody i don't know what he would want
a nuke for but i can tell you that
at the time the second second amendment
was created corsairs and privateers were
all the rage
so when the founding fathers had the
right to bear arms they legit knew that
people had artillery and they knew that
people actually had their own warships
i think i i think that we should have as
few people with nukes as possible
that's my hot tape we're talking about
tanks here don't you dare fill a buster
here
okay what's wrong with an individual
having his own personal
soul specifically the specific question
was not whether you should have a tank
but whether you should be able to have a
tank with intact artillery
if you just want to have a tank to drive
around i'm okay with that the artillery
system
no sorry i don't know why because i just
think it's dangerous i think there's got
to be a line somewhere
a forks are dangerous because they make
people fat someone could punch you in
the face
right has everyone i don't ever walk up
to and punch you in the face
i've been slapped so like i was thinking
about this when we were at the range you
have all these people all over the place
with guns and they're shooting and i was
just thinking like
at any point someone could you know
shoot somebody else but
it's not going to happen because people
don't want to hurt each other now
sometimes people do like to do the kill
dozer you know what i mean
so i think ultimately the challenge is i
probably you're probably right
and don't give people are you know full
intact artillery shells
but the dude built the kill those are no
one could stop him he only he only
the killdozer guy only got stopped
because he fell into a basement yep
but if someone really wanted to do
something they'll do it i guess nowadays
the cia is spying on everybody so if you
tried to build a killdozer they'd come
for you you know and
i also think it's just kind of funny
watching libertarians freak out when i
say i don't like tanks
libertarians on twitter and i count
myself among libertarians but they
they it's funny watching them it is it
is interesting like look at the east
india trading company there's a massive
corporation with warships all over the
place
and just did their thing and it was like
pretty brutal and authoritarian in a lot
of ways you know
it's tough i think the issue is at a
certain point
nuclear weapons are probably a line i
think for everybody you don't want bill
gates with a nuke i don't know i don't
think he would fire it but i don't want
anybody any like
i don't want russian i barely want a
nuke i really want any governments to
have nukes
i would rather none of them did well i
mean putin has nukes and those are his
but those as few people i actually am
really this is maybe one of my nerd
areas i'm really worried about nuclear
war
you know that during the during the cold
war there was actually a situation where
they almost launched all the nukes yeah
we talked about it we talked about it
and then
friday yeah we talked about it friday
isn't that crazy yeah
they have like nuclear submarines all
along the coasts yeah we don't know
about how many
nuclear subs are in the world right so
all i'm saying is we need as little
more of that as possible i think you i
think you're right about long-range
artillery first get rid of
the government's nuclear weapons then we
could talk about tanks so i would love
that
the problem is like i wish we actually
could get rid of all the governments
but you could never like like nuclear
disarmament as a strategy is like oh
well only the good guys are going to go
along with it yeah
so just to clarify you're not you don't
want to take away people's tanks you
want to take away people's artillery
yes all right we got a super chat here
from wyoming trailer trash he says aloha
tim would you please ask lydia to dm
stixxenhammer 666 and razerfist on
twitter
an extended invitation for your show
while stixx is back in the states
sticks he's back in the states standing
invitation to join us
of course sticks was great yeah that'd
be awesome to have him here cody says
try some three and a half inch 12-gauge
slugs you'll have fun then
oh yeah eric brits has tried firing a 10
gauge sometime
i just we're talking now about the
journalists who panicked over the recoil
on a five
we're assuming it's a five five six i
imagine it would be it looks like a five
five six from the photos that i'm seeing
there
it's just not even that much you know
it's just slugs are fun
yeah slugs are fun ricky bobby says
ever since i got into crypto about 10
months ago i get ads on youtube
for black girl stocks could you imagine
if i tried making white boy stocks the
double standard is absolutely insane
ps polkadot to the moon okay polkadot's
incredible it's not a security so you
can't get in the united states
oh really yeah technically i'd say say
tim i recommend you check out a song
called
knives guns and bed by rare americans
the song is a representation
of china and america fighting
interesting timothy peterson says on the
ar-15 ptst
tip when we first went to range in basic
training our drill sergeant put an m16
against his crotch and fired off three
rounds to demonstrate low recoil
love it when msm refers to two two three
five five six has high power
seriously we have a 308 which was fun
at the range and it's just like what is
this guy doing he's never
like i i'm sorry i gotta bring it back
to how funny it is to imagine
like a teenager going turkey hunting
with his family and that's
more recoil than this guy had and he
can't handle that
people seriously jeez oh okay so matthew
doherty says steven crowder announced
today
that he will be involved in a lawsuit
against a big tech and he plans to join
in or do something similar
me no but i did see that jack pasobic
tweeted something about amazon
and mail in voting and twitter labeled
it as disputed
and i think that might be grounds for a
defamation suit against twitter because
twitter made the statement
so if you tweet something about so
amazon recently said we don't want mail
in votes we want in person secure
and then he tweeted saying like they're
saying mail and voting is you know
insecure
twitter put an auto flag on it saying
this claim about voter fraud is disputed
blah blah blah
but it's not disputed everyone agrees
the media agrees
jeff bezos did say this that's a false
statement of fact so what would the
claim be against
against twitter twitter made the
statement by putting a statement on jack
posobix tweet
twitter publicly stated jack posobik is
wrong
but he's a public figure so he has a
really high definition standard which
would be
uh knowing that what he said was true
and correct and still putting the flag
there anyway which is the challenge
because if it was done by an algorithm
that's what i was going to say is like i
you you have to prove intent it's like i
got sued by roy moore
right for an article i wrote criticizing
him yeah fun fact about me
but like one article i wrote was not
false at all but even if it was he would
have had to prove that i
knew it was false and published it
anyway so the public standard
public figure standard is so high it's
like barely anyone can ever reach it
matthew reckamp says in several videos
tim seemingly justified the cancellation
of the xl pipeline by mentioning the 29
leaks
from my view there are questions that
need to be answered how
how severe were the leaks how many is
that compared to other transportation
methods is it worth the oil being sent
likely to china
uh i think it's unfair to say i
seemingly justify the cancellation in my
latest video i said i have no strong
opinions one way or the other
i understand the argument that it
actually creates less emissions
transporting the oil by pipeline than by
freight or by trucks
and i don't know the amount of spills
we've got from uh freight or from trucks
so
it's hard to know who's right or wrong
on the issue the point i was making is
that
these unions endorsed the pipeliners
union endorsed biden
and politico was like even though he
says he's gonna ban keystone
they did it anyway and then when he bans
keystone they're like oh oh no
oh geez how could he do this and i'm
like you knew he was gonna do it
you're not really outraged you're
pretending because you're manipulating
your your members did he ban fracking
he put a moratorium on it okay on
federal land
so what conservatives are doing now is
they're saying aha see he banned
fracking
and they're missing the last part of
that on federal land for
60 days and the left is saying he didn't
ban fracking
ignoring that he did actually ban some
fracking so it's like you said before
talking past each other right
you know moral of the story everyone's
wrong yes everyone's wrong
i mean it's fair to say he banned some
fracking right you gotta put the sum in
there otherwise people think he just
outright banned friends and he
temporarily banned it
right 60 days and you know we'll see how
things play out but i think it's
we think he i think he's going to do it
or it's it's fair to say that he was
lying to all those people who asked him
when he was like oh we're going to get
rid of it trust me but he also
the thing is he and kamala both said
both things on different occasions on
the campaign
exactly sometimes he said yes we will
ban it sometimes he said we'll just ban
it on federal lands or some other things
and also if america becomes less energy
independent we have more of
an excuse to go into the middle east and
joe biden doesn't need much of an excuse
to do that
orange field 2 says lydia can we book
someone to actually disagree with you
guys
have an appropriate polite debate it
seems like an echo chamber and no one
learns anything love your show though
well we invite many leftists but they're
scared of coven and i don't mean that
disrespectfully i mean
literally we've invited many leftists
high profile ones and they're like i'll
do your show and then it's like
we'll buy your ticket we'll get whoa
whoa in person
yes the show is in person we don't have
any setup and i don't intend to do
skype or digital stuff it just doesn't
work it doesn't it doesn't work at all
it's everyone sits there and then yells
at each other while their chats go off
and they argue back
having someone in here in person is how
you do it and unfortunately
it is a fact gallop has the poles the
left is terrified of coba they won't
travel
there are even some like rational and
legit leftists i really like that say
the same thing they're scared of coven
conservatives don't seem to care at all
look at this guy sitting there with no
mask on
no i mean we're all socially distant
actually which is interesting we are
more or less but
i guess the thing is i also think it's
also hard to get leftists to come on
your podcast period
at least that's been my experience is
i've reached out to a bunch of people
and they don't really seem i would go on
msnbc i go on rachel maddow i'd be like
anytime i don't know that a lot of
leftists really are willing to engage
i've had there's one leftist i really
like and he said to me
like i really appreciate the invite to
be honest there's no upside for me
coming on your show
and i'm like you're right big audience
but do they not care about reaching
they don't they don't think that the
people who watch this show is going to
benefit them in any way so why would
they bother doing it
unless they make clips for leftists
that's just an alien mentality to me
though
at least if you're doing this kind of
thing you should care about reaching
people
with your with your message and your
voice and it shouldn't just be reaching
people of a certain persuasion or you're
doing it wrong
i've always been of the of the ilk of
like communication first
get through to the human and then if we
want to talk about ideas and whatever
but as long as you connect with the
human
doesn't really matter who you're talking
to all right we got a super chat here
from crystalmac76
i love your rv luke maybe you should
invite someone random to wake tim up
a tired tim and a beanie it sounds like
a party keep the members only content
coming thanks guys
i like the way you're thinking and since
you did this to me i now have
been granted permission officially by
the internet and the rules of super
chats
not the same to you yes you you you
changed it all when when i knocked on
your door and you were sleeping
and what did you say to me what i don't
think i can repeat it
well i don't know if you change the
rules what are you just leaving i
banged on your door and then you i'm not
gonna say it i'll leave it there
wait wait wait wait wait wait do you
sleep in the beanie is that what i got
from this you sleep in the beanie no i
got these really nice little little
boxers you ever sleep in the bb
why would i just fall asleep i feel like
it's your thing no i take it off on the
couch every day what do you mean
i'm sitting there watching what do you
watch family guy or whatever and i'll
play hearthstone on the tablet
and then i you know let me know who i
should surprise tim with
uh feel free to reach out to me anymore
lauren southern
what's she up to she was on route she
was in australia
yeah she was oh she was on ribbon
somebody's show she had a new
documentary yeah that's you know
all right andrew yang that's my other
guest hey tim i got a thousand dollar
check for you right here
uh universal basic income for you that'd
be a good one
you're real avila says tim what is your
prediction on godzilla versus king kong
i don't care for giant monster movies
never cared
pacific ranch king kong all the way i
guess
i'm pious i guess
ready to rumble says your website needs
a comment section under the videos
us beanie boys need to converse there is
a comment section under all of the
videos
that's there and all of them it is yeah
so become a member and then you can
comment and everyone talks to each other
and it's good fun
brian bourgeois says why aren't we
talking about solutions we can complain
all day i know it's hard but we need to
talk about solutions because we do
it's building culture because the
culture war is where
the war is happening and politics is
only after the fact so we've been
talking about doing vlog content
we just put up a video where alex jones
walks into luke's rv and wakes him up
and there's nothing political in it you
are fully exploiting me
to the closest but it's because we have
like five videos up
yeah and it's the one we put up where
it's literally just you're watching alex
be like hey luke i just drove here how
you been
and luke's like and they're like we're
gonna go get food and it's like it's not
political it's just regular
so that's the point is to to make fun
and silly stuff and that's part of the
solution it is we could do talk about
flash graphing if you want to talk about
solving for the future technology but
we got to have an expert on yeah on
which objective or graphene
flash graphing just a formula oh yeah
for sure i'd love to get an expert on
like directed energy weapons too
all right let's see where we're at we
got too many super chats coming in this
is crazy
unreasonably angry says fully functional
a-10s are a god-given right
what's an a-10 i think that's a shotgun
uh that is only for military use i don't
know i'm just guessing here
let me look that up tyler woods says i
just finished ann jacobson's untold
history of area 51.
black projects and funding exploded
after sputnik as bad as the us was
during the cold war falling behind
technologically would have been way more
terrifying to me oh i agree yeah yeah
let's see corny says you should get the
same you should get the same guest jimmy
dore had the other day or the boogaloo
boy guy
i mean maybe i i wouldn't want to just
be like oh jimmy dore interviewed him i
better interview him too because i think
you should watch jimmy dore's interview
of him you know he's getting a lot of
criticism
on twitter because he was trending yeah
and nationwide
a-10 is a fighter jet by the way yeah so
jimmy interviewed a boogaloo boy
who was like very pro left culturally on
a bunch of issues
he said like pro lgbt pro blm all this
stuff
and then the what the response from the
established was he's lying he's far
right
it's like why why is he fall right that
makes no sense antifa wants the same
things as him it's ridiculous i'm not
going to say they're far left
that would be ridiculous too but you
know whatever none of that makes sense
all right let's see where we will do a
couple more
guarant says stixx is under a concerted
attack to smear him as a nazi they got
sarah carter to tar him to put him
to so put him on now he's hot and will
get views and it will protect the guy
he's good
well i'm not super concerned about
getting views from having sticks on i
think six is all right
i don't know what they're saying about
him as much as as far as i can tell he's
like a
fairly libertarian commentator yeah and
then i realized people were smearing him
i do not agree with those smears
lucas kaiser says have you heard of
bunker brands they make t-shirts got to
love matt how many demos out there
we've heard like you reached out to me i
reached out to them they didn't respond
yet well you know we'll see yeah
what do we have here what's this stinky
ugly says i bought a 308 ar-10 and it's
brought me joy
second only to my wife
i do call my uh firearms girlfriends so
kid truck says did you guys know that
gatling guns are legal in many states
really no that's the crank that's what i
want
do you ever see the video i think
mythbusters did it they did a steam
gatling gun
where they basically had a steam engine
spin really fast
and what it would do is once it lined up
with with like the barrel
it would sling a bullet out it was crazy
something like that
yeah that's cool railguns are cool too
man
all right let's see we'll just do a
couple more
jonathan says interview a critical race
theorist so they can
educate y'all okay we should do a
sponsored video where we do
uh a behind-the-scenes critical race
theory class for everyone here
yeah mandatory diversity training love
to get some progress i don't like the
word progressive
what it means what it's become but like
cortez
rashida toled corey bush just somebody
that's like
so out there on the other end of the
spectrum just have them in
let's let's like i don't think they
would and learn we'll be nice
you know we've had
all the time the problem is when people
bully us to try and force their way on
the show
but anyway here we go the last one the
most important one
alessio de monte says can you add a 480p
on the videos on your website my
internet sucks
the good news is moving forward all
videos we have a new player which allows
all the way down to 144p up to 1080 you
can customize
so you can stream better it is a better
player it is easier to load we are
constantly improving the site
but the key to a successful business is
to just start doing it
if you try and build this massive castle
before anyone's come you might find that
people don't actually want to use it and
then you got to change everything
so you start like like we did we're
going to re reformat the whole layout of
the site we're going to be adding more
kinds of content
better video players we're just slowly
going to be improving it over time so
make sure you go to timcast.com
become a member because we're going to
be producing more and more members-only
content we're probably
expanding like crazy as this ramps up
because it's really it's taking off and
you guys are awesome
but i want to make a network that is is
huge
i want to do eventually like a 24 hour
live stream where we have like
different people hosting different news
segments of the day just make it really
this big
you know network of content a variety of
issues and
you know skateboarding music culture
games everything just
take it off and we're getting there we
are getting there so go to timecast.com
become a member
we should have a bonus segment up later
today hopefully we'll see how things
play out but uh
brad you want to mention your social
media and anything people should check
out
yeah absolutely thanks for having me on
and if people want to follow me it's
brad underscore palumbo p-o-l-u-m-b-o
and most importantly podcast is breaking
boundaries with brad palumbo on apple
podcast and spotify
well today i'm wearing one of my
favorite personal shirts that says
i wear crystals i burn sage i meditate i
fast and i still want to slap
some people upside the head and you get
that shirt and many others the new ones
that were banned are coming back
and they are all available on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com if you if you
want to find out more about me check out
we are change.org
uh hey guys thanks for coming i'm ian
crossland you can follow me on social
media i love you
and i appreciate a lot of what you have
said and done
for me in the last uh in the last months
it's been very nice ditto
and i am sour patch lids uh i am that on
twitter and minds and then i am real
sour patch lids on
instagram and oh my gosh i'm still
managing to blank
on gab yeah there we go all right there
i finally got all my socials that's me
you can follow me if you want to
and you can follow me on twitter
instagram and minds at tim cast whether
or not i actually post there
you know anymore it's just because it's
just those are awful mines is cool
and uh but you know as far as instagram
goes instagram's alright i like posting
there sometimes
twitter is just ugh twitter but uh you
know you can follow me there you get it
special thanks to our sponsor today
virtual shield once again you can go to
surfinginternetsafe.com and i'm really
grateful they sponsored the show
we'll have some membership members on
the content at timcast.com coming up
in a little bit so thanks for hanging
out and we will see we'll be back
live tomorrow at 8pm and we will see you
all then
you